you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work and
no don't mess around end up hurting them
I say the wrong thing make it personal
you said the wrong thing I might hurt
I'm about to sip on some six-year age
whistle pig piggyback 100 Proof Single
Barrel Bourbon whiskey
from busting with the boys yeah bro and
the Creator himself over here this is
Will Compton I would say
um
outside of Creator there's about four
they give us like eight selections and
we had to narrow it down don't set
yourself short dude I'm just saying
you're the guy who created this thing
whiskey that I'm about to try four years
you know what I'm saying you put some
time into this we went out had a nice
little visit we were drunk the entire
time
yeah yeah but you know you got a good
time it is good though I've heard you
wanna you wanna you want you want me to
describe what you're gonna taste yeah
let's hear it you're gonna taste a
little heat up front a little heat
you're going to be a little spicy a
little Spice in the front like a little
haunted house yeah you're not gonna know
what's going on your back you're gonna
take a swig and you're gonna be like oh
no I hope this goes down smooth I don't
want to so I don't want to soil my boy
right now yeah and then it's gonna go
down your throat yeah think of yourself
in the backyard on a hammock on a nice
sunny day down your throat and then as
you know it sits nicely warm on top of
your stomach oh damn that's what you're
gonna take
and see if I need to know if that if
that's the correct description
it's almost spot on it comes on pretty
strong yeah it makes you nervous it's
like you jumped on a grenade the fat
girl comes on strong and then the night
it's smooth yeah
this is nice brother
how's it and how's it been going you
guys just
it's like for you because it's uh you
don't have to give me all the details we
can talk after but it's like a ref share
deal right it's your logo you guys push
on your show it's WhistlePig product
correct Barstool does all of our all of
our ad Revenue sales so that's like a
split Revenue deal uh I think they know
what they're doing yeah yeah or so you
know they're they're [__] on top of
the food chest for like a reason but
they do all the sales so when when
whistlepick came on board they wanted to
grow their brand in Boston and Nashville
and they want to push between our brand
and then KFC radio oh yeah because KFC
Kevin has his own right yeah is that why
you guys start that beef you in KFC yes
so that so I guess he's my boy KFC's a
stud you're my boy yeah yeah so I'll
kill KFC which I appreciate yes and I
need guys like you on my side I can do
that KFC's he's a lot bigger in person
I'll be your Liam Neeson
um but no that he he was just talking
[__] because I had left this dinner
Dave
so this is set this thing this is Super
Bowl Sunday Super Bowl week we're out in
Arizona bar stool of course are doing
their thing out there and they took over
basically I saw you guys all yeah yeah
gain on who else you have on Christian
McCaffrey Fred Warner now here's a
little thing here you know like coach
Christian McCaffrey when he's a kid you
coached him uh some say you got his
moves from me yeah I did Coach himself
so how was this how was uh how's his
how's his old man while you're the Ed
McCaffrey was my hero growing up bro
because he was white receiver he was my
first action figure of course yeah white
receiver my old man was like hey yeah
yeah you want to be like him he's the
guy yeah I'm saying yeah I love the
bills for whatever reason so I had a
Thurman Thomas I had a Thurman Thomas
action figure too but dude I'm a one-up
you're not a Bryce pop action figure for
the bills bro and Don BB yeah come at me
bro but but Ed McCaffrey's like hey son
that was my guy yeah yeah yeah six four
two twenty five my goals get to 25 and I
just kind of kept going past that so
we'll talk about that later but yeah
Christian McCaffrey uh because he would
run a football summer Camp his dad would
with Lauren Landau who was the strength
condition coach of the Broncos and he's
my best friend that name he's one of my
best before he was destroying the
conditioning coach for the Broncos he
had a big name
Manning's guy Tim Tebow's guy he was my
guy he had a nice facility yeah okay
yeah
I think his land out performance so then
he got the job with the Broncos but
before that he would run these huge
summer camps he's the man like Peyton
Manning's guy like I said Tim Tebow so
he do those camps he's like hey will you
help out with the camera yeah sure and
then I didn't know it was Ed McCaffrey's
son I was like who the [__] is that
little white boy he's like freak right
like I've never seen footwork like that
he's like uh his dad's at McCaffrey and
now his other brother's a badass too so
both of them bro
no one could touch them their house so
grown up they would get grounded if they
got Jersey tackled in a game when
they're seven or eight years old and
that's what I'm gonna do with my kids
and Christian was even he wasn't nervous
to tell that story but there were a
couple stories like I'm gonna you know
withhold from saying bro
I'm saying outlier you're like oh my God
I was like he's gonna Heisman and the
dad's like you think I'm like you know
better than me but I think so like you
know that ego says so he's going to be a
freaky one I mean he is Chris
McCaffrey's so back to the Super Bowl so
he said Chris McCaffrey
uh yeah best linebacker in the league
yeah Jeffree Star was an instant one
right because the rumor was that you
Taylor who's your podcast host yeah was
hooking up with him or her whatever she
goes by yeah Jeffree Star he goes by him
he hates the pronoun [__] he thinks
that's all that was all built out of
boredom during covid and uh hilarious
but Jeffree Star posted a photo talking
about his NFL Boo and it looked like it
and it had it had like it had tats on
the hand or tats on the leg well it
wasn't Taylor though that picture's not
Taylor yeah it just well that was the
first photo and then there was a second
one where there's uh you get the
backside in the middle that looks like
Taylor in college or younger yes spot on
but she actually he actually has an NFL
boo though I think unfortunately that
day I had go and I was going to we were
going to Kabula next week and I had a I
had like an emergency passport situation
going so I'd like drive down to Tucson
Arizona so I missed a Fred Warner one
who I would have loved to [__] have
in the Jeffree Star one so Taylor did
them by himself so Taylor did those by
himself but but essentially Taylor had
leaned into the joke because he was
getting tagged by everybody and he was
like am I in Wyoming question mark and
that started to blow up and then you
know how it is you start leaning into
that content a little bit more it starts
blowing up Taylor's starting to say
other things his wife ends up getting
involved saying like Wednesday are going
to be back home yeah I'm getting in I'm
like hey just let me know when you're
gonna be back Jeffree star's like uh
when can I come on the podcast I'm like
whenever you and Taylor get back from
Wyoming we're doing all of this stuff
right now from outside looking I was
like oh no question yeah it's still
being talked about like which I was like
that's cool yeah when Taylor Taylor just
got uh Taylor just got cut recently and
posted a photo of uh uh the trash bags
on front of his house but everyone was
blowing that up but he's getting covered
on like Tick Tock from some of these
Tick Tock people are
that's a good treatment but everybody
was blowing up about that but he's being
covered like on Tick Tock by uh Hey
ex-nfl Big Boo suspect from Jeffree Star
like that's always that's how much it
was blowing up did he care
the Taylor there were a couple times he
was like you know was like maybe the
should I keep leaning into this and
we're everybody was kind of like yeah
bro bro it's hilarious Jeffree Star I'm
thinking I'm thinking Tosh point no I'm
thinking Daniel Tosh like bro let
everyone just assume that you're just a
sweetheart Timmy Dylan style yeah you're
a little too sweet out there but uh we
and then uh Jeffrey was like Hey I'm
gonna be in Arizona for the Super Bowl
and Tara's like yo would you do a
podcast continue to lean into this thing
they make content together uh it all
worked out it was awesome I saw Taylor
post he was like because he was like all
you bigots out there amazing the amount
of hate we're getting he's like you
[__] idiot yes there's there's
definitely been proud boys right there
showing some true colors like just like
oh I'm instantly [__] I'm done with
busting with the boys interviewing this
thing boys
what the [__] yeah what insecure did you
have yeah I know you like to suck dick
yeah because you're triggered by this
yeah and Jeffree Star is like and
Jeffrey's dope yeah Jeffrey's
business-wise is a Monster yeah and he's
got all these guns he's talking about
hell it's so confusing because he hates
all the pronouns
somebody like me to say that you he's
talking to Taylor you can't say that
because obviously yeah yeah but uh
Jeffrey ends up coming on the Pod who
else do we get on yeah Dana White
Christian McCaffrey Fred how's Dana Dana
was awesome Dana was [__] awesome he
came from Radio row super like
accommodating he invited us out to power
slap next week
no we're we're going yeah yeah I want to
hit the machine I want to know what to
see how this can do yeah because it
takes so much talent to slap yeah
it's a it's a very
I have no issue with doing it any faster
the power slap thing makes no sense to
me why not for a guy so smart I'm like
what are you doing dude well hang on
like you've moved the ball this far for
the the UFC and you know just a few
years ago they're referring to as [__]
fighting then and this were a guy who
grew up playing football like alpha male
top 10 UFC I like yeah you're in the
Octagon I like girls look at your ears
yeah yeah slap fighting I'm like oh no
this is too much like this is stupid
just guys getting CTE for no reason for
sure but yeah Force Griffin like holy
[__] like grab them shout out to force
Griffin but he's just grabbing the guy
so they don't hit their head after they
get concussed and then so how does that
work because I want to talk about the
business stuff too but if they get you
know they get concussed they black on
phone do you like a eight count they put
it back on their feet they get an eight
count to just lay there and then they
lift them up and they just say hey are
you good yeah you're good to go and they
go yeah I'm good I'm gonna slap them
again I'm all about it sure I can't
believe it's ancient 2023. absolutely I
mean you're right about that but at the
same time it's like yo if these like
truck drivers and everybody else wants
to get into the slide game and make a
few extra dollars but how far how far
should we go should we put World Star
Hip-Hop shooting videos on there like
how far you want to go like in Dana's
whole uh like excuse was like it goes
well you know on Tick Tock like people
want to make friends because the ratings
suck dick I get bigger ratings than that
show so he's like it does better on Tick
Tock it beats the UFC or NFL and Tick
Tock it's like yeah but the the girls in
high school beating up another girl do
better videos than tick tock on UFC so
what's your point there well based off
Tick Tock he's I he's basing it off I in
my opinion he's basing off how the
generation how the short attention spans
are becoming like fair you see them slap
videos like you sit there look at it
several times because you're like what
these [__] dudes are eating what are
you gonna watch it every Wednesday for
an hour no no no I don't I don't think
on TV I don't I don't you know probably
won't do that it's not like you're gonna
sit there by who you know we got so and
so minus 270 like it is interesting like
I tune in too I'm a psychopath I'm a
sociopath I'll watch I'm like oh this is
insane and laughs she's like I can't
believe this is on TV but B like think
about it like think of think of all the
athletes who get that close and don't
make it and and they truly don't know
what they're going to do and they think
they're strong enough and can get in
this slide game and they get thrown a
few thousand dollars to do slide game
they're going to pursue pursue a slave
career I'm telling you to either buy him
like two grand bro they don't bump you
out and it follows me up it's not like a
question are they gonna get CT it's like
no no hold on 100 if you sign up for
this day Numero Uno not like over the
years today all of your NCT I think I
wear these rash guards you know because
your tits are splashing around your
gut's hanging out like You Gotta Wear
and they say you can't bend your knees
too much yeah you can't like rotate yeah
they say you can't Flinch yeah yeah like
bro you gotta
no no not at all but I'll watch people
do it like it's universally understood
you guys were shortening your lifespan
here but you know period but you realize
like it's not like Dana's uh you know
reinvented the wheel here Russia has
been doing this forever oh there's
Russia does like medieval sliding on
there this isn't this there can't be
some Reinventing the wheel no no it's
not like people like oh there's a slap
Fight League he's like bro in Russia
it's been going on since the 1800s it's
not you know he's just it's part of
their education right I think the part
that rubs a lot of people wrong is he
used the UFC platform which is a legit
League it'd be like the NFL Showcase in
uh Lingerie Football right it'd be like
using the NFL platform to just push
Lingerie Football everyone's like hey
you know we're here for the real [__]
too don't don't push the this whatever
this is give us the real [__] like we're
following it for the NFL so when you use
the UFC's name that he's built that the
best ever do it by the way the best
promoter of all time hands down
brilliant man just this is the one time
where I'm like that doesn't and I get
business and like that doesn't make
sense
that's fair I mean that's fair but if
you're him and you have the platform
like the UFC like I get why you know I
think I get why people are would be
upset about it I'm not sure do you well
I'm saying I'm just talking about the
audience like people hey they're getting
some backlash but I I think like
ultimately he's trying he would you know
why you know I think he shows when I saw
that I was like he's bored
he's bored you have 400 million dollars
in the bank
you sort of slap lately bro and then you
pay him two grand it's like and then
you're going you're doing the model you
did in the [__] in the 90s that
screwed over the fight apparently
there's a training regimen for this oh I
know he's like we're having a combine
I'm like how's that go down guys doing
vertical but I want to be there like 13
inch verticals yeah I want to be there I
would cover that yeah yeah
the more we talk about the more excited
I'm getting yeah it sounds just like a
complete [__] show right yeah but you
would just want to lean into the [__]
show yeah like yo we're talking about
how are we gonna find this next slapper
who's the next slapper to be you know
what I mean yeah it's interesting it's
definitely interesting I'll tell you
he's not gonna be in the slap Fight
League is the man walking out right now
Bo nickel do you know much about this
kid no not at all
yeah let me feel it on Beau nickel he's
the great white hype he's the next
American hero we need him America needs
him like dagestanians Brazilians have
been owned in the UFC for a long time
he's from Rifle Colorado shout out to
Rifle Colorado Colorado boy wrestled at
Penn State one of the best amateur
wrestlers of all time he won the Heisman
for wrestlers in college he's a [__]
freak how old is he ah man was he
mid-20s 27 so he missed the Olympic team
he lost the guy who ended up winning
gold and then he pursued MMA he's he's
he's our version of Daniel Haas Trophy
winner there it is yeah there it is and
that's their Heisman for college
wrestling he's um he's the close thing
we have to like a LeBron in the UFC like
he's supposed to be the next thing so he
went on Dana White's Contender series
and just mopped the floor like I think
his longest fight was a minute 20. and
then he he had he had one fight and
destroyed the kid and usually get a
contract and he's like this is only your
third fight like you got to get one more
he's like okay to give him that kid and
usually never but guess on food truck if
they're fighting because you can get
hurt and they get canceled yeah but the
guy's like hey uh bo nickers wants to do
fight campaign on Thursday but he fights
Wednesday and I go book him you know
what do you mean guaranteed wins doesn't
get touched like really I'm like book
him goes in there starch is the dude in
59 seconds Savage is he the guy to where
the odds are like minus over two
thousand yeah he's like a minus three
thousand or some [__]
so he's gonna work this guy now how's he
going to finish him he'll finish this
guy probably uh Jiu Jitsu his Jitsu they
have him as a blue belt but his skill
levels he's he does a lot of black belt
things he's a [__] freak so is he
gonna tap this dude out 100 and it it
won't go past the first round he so he's
a minus 2100 that's insane minus 2100
yeah dude this would be one of the
biggest upsets of all time if Jamie
Pickett could like land in a punch
I mean does he have a shot he has a
punch his chance and also he has what
was that 20 he has 21 fights Bo nickel
has three but Bo nickel has been on that
wrestling circuit since he was a kid in
big big crowd so this moment can't get
big enough so 185 I mean and that's a
bigger body too it's not like 185 but
then also I'm I'm so confident Bo nickel
unless they gave him like a top three
guy nobody's touching him he'll be
anybody not in the top three now in the
top three he could get a little dicey
would like he right away like he got
into the UFC he's like I want Hamza like
who's a monster everyone scared him he's
like I want him right now there's like
slow down so they can give him this guy
after this though if he starts with this
kid he's like three fights away from
fighting top ten like yeah 100 we're
banking on him Americans need him we
know how soon how soon uh I bet he'll be
fighting for World title in under two
years
a year and a half I'm excited yeah I'm
excited oh no he's a freak yeah and he's
such a good dude you guys gotta have him
on your show such a good dude did I love
to have there's just something that it's
wrestlers are just different we had
Spencer Lee on the podcast that kid's
just a different animal but Dan Hodge
bro you remember do you remember him
Daniel Hodge oh he would go around so in
the circuit with the triple crown and
everything else was like Cliff Keen and
the wrestling stuff back in the Daniel
Hodge would come around and he was the
guy known for like ripping phone books
and half squeezing yeah
yeah but he's like one of the greatest
wrestlers obviously yeah to step on the
mat yep yeah this he he's one of these
kids and then he trains out of uh State
College and has his own like ATT Center
there it's all circuit like based around
him Mike Brown goes up there they fly in
training partners for him up there like
he's such a Savage I mean and you got
he's got the right fan base too you got
the wrestling community at your back
dude and he's like uh the other thing he
has on his side is his first I think two
fights were on Fight Pass on it's the
most viewed thing ever on Fight Pass his
two fights really whenever he fought on
there they get the most views which is
probably because everybody loved them in
the wrestling game yeah massive
wrestling fan base and then you'll see
remember he has three fights watch his
movement watch you get starched in 30
seconds don't kick like that though
now this Jamie Pickett his entire game
plan is like don't get taken down
he's trying to stay on his feet 100 he's
doing a pretty damn good job
and then I was asking Bo when he came on
food truck I was like dude all these
tacky standings are taken over he
worried about that and he started
laughing he goes bro I've been competing
against Douglas day and since I was 10
years old I go and how'd you do he goes
I never lost he was it's rare they'd
even score a point on me yo he's I think
I'm pretty sure old boy just got needed
it too I'm pretty sure like straight in
the [__] nuts oh he hasn't he has a
submission here no I think he was trying
to complain then oh boy he just can't
yeah Bo just tossed him
and he also showed up in a Royals Royce
Phantom
which is very unrestling like already
that is yes but but you want him you
want him uh shown up in like an old Ford
Ranger
I was going to crank on the neck there a
little bit
no chances kid people uh head arm trying
to come in hot he's gonna step over the
body and choke him out ready and three
two this guy's like holy [__] yo I'm
telling you pick it wants to back up and
go to that knee to the crotch I swear to
God Pig gets asking about a slap fight
contract
what's that look like I don't wrestle
there he's gonna tap that right head on
there he goes if he can step over
oh his return the the thing to do is
just turn away there he goes if he turns
away he'll be okay how brutal is it to
be in like an almost a mission like this
and see that there's still over three
minutes left well it's more brutal not
to be doing the right technique to get
out of it but uh also Beau needs to get
off to the side
like you see how he's still in Mount
yeah he'll be able to apply more
pressure he needs to get off to the side
behind him uh behind him and then Jamie
Pickett should be rolling to his right
not into it most guys your natural
reactions roll into it makes it tighter
so it should be rolling away from it
and I
it's weird that Bo's keeping that knee
inside there
because he can reposition
you know it's getting tight
real tight see step oh I don't know why
he's keeping that see there you go there
you go
and so that defense called the phone
phone technique where like they say
answering the phone but really should be
turning away
a lot of energy for her bow though to
get this done I don't know why he's
staying in [__] Mountain he just step
over and get what's he trying to do is
he just trying to put his shoulder in
his hand yeah driving his [__] show
he's about to tap
oh look at him he went oh my God
both just oh there he goes it's gonna be
tighter now there you go
holy [__] disappointed took three
minutes
well he went back down took three
minutes you didn't get touched I think
pick is going to go back to this uh knee
to the crotch
somebody may hit me in the nuts I'm
telling you this kid's ready for top ten
he's one of the very few guys because
I'm always like hey it's not Sprint it's
a marathon he's the one guy I'm like put
him up there he's the one guy I believe
in his wrestling is it's just his
wrestling now would they would they uh
storyline him similar to like like
giving all these fights to them similar
like they've been doing like sugar Shawn
O'Malley yeah like he's just been
finding a lot of different people it
seems like but even she'll get out of
there even sugar they they built him up
let him get a star shining like Bo
Nichols has more
more hype around him than sugar he's
more hype around than any Patty pimlet
all these guys just from the three
wrestling background and then three
fights they haven't been I don't think
he's been touched I literally don't
think he's been touched yo how how is uh
how is Patty
because he's a bar stool kid yeah I know
but he you know he's obviously across
the pond but when he's not there he's in
San Diego yeah he had him on yeah no he
would be awesome and going he's got an
electric personality but I want to say
the last fight he had didn't he have
like something questionable going on
yeah most people think he lost that
fight including Joe Rogan I thought do
you think he lost that fight uh I can
see how people think he lost that fight
I don't think he was like a robbery like
we've definitely seen bigger robberies
you know but yeah yeah it was a tough
fight for him for sure very tough fight
for him very tough fight he definitely
and he looking back on it he was like
he's like I thought I dominated he was I
watched the tape I did not dominate like
yeah some close [__] people right
because it's always it was tough to tell
with like Patty because obviously he's
with barcel so he's got a lot of juice
and energy behind him you don't know if
it's like somebody coming over from from
that side kind of like a Conor McGregor
or somebody but that's why you get so
much hate because I think he has the
backing of bar stool and people like
dude he's fighting Jared Gordon Jordan
Levitt like he's not there yet and but
he has all this hype he has this
seven-figure deal with Barstool so I
think that's where the hate comes from
yeah and obviously because you know
Marshall is going to blow up any I mean
he's got the backing of bar so they're
going to back him they're going to be
like they do they sit in the close to
the front row they're going to be
promoting them the entire time saying
that also after noise saying fight of
the night dude and that's after that
Jared Gorn fight which I would say 99
people think you lost that fight and I
I'm a huge fan so I might be a little
biased I can see how you'd give it to
the other guy but yeah close [__] 90
of people thought Patty lost that fight
yes and then when when Portnoy is on the
mic and going Dana bonus 50 Grand bonus
everyone's like [__] you dude yeah so
that it's like the perfect storm
remember he's like 26 years old and
people want to hate him it's like get
the [__] out of here yeah he's a young
kid you know how it is the poor noise
like porno he's like he's he's like
polarizing the people yeah you don't
know him you think he's gonna love him
or hate them yeah but if so if you're on
that team like if they hate Portnoy
they're gonna hate Patty panel right it
just goes handy just us directly that's
why you get so much backlash which okay
yeah whatever and then also he's he's
also a guy that you know I was because
when I interviewed him he fights at uh
155. I interviewed him he got he was 220
pounds which is unheard of he was like
straight up fat like talk about thick
boy dude Jesus Christ
he does yeah because he you know and he
talks about depression [__] like that so
he blew the [__] up and I go dude what
happens if they call you with like a
once in a lifetime opportunity to fight
for the title so they started laughing
because I would never find a short
notice make too much money outside the
Octagon to fight stupid because they
couldn't pay me enough I make too much
money not fighting I was good for you to
just be like I would plan it out and
yeah I gotta have to do a proper Camp
it's not worth it jumping in there
taking a loss he's gonna make too much
money it'll affect my brand I'm like
good for you yeah that is nice isn't
that dope yeah it's a nice one him and
sugar are like the only guys I know that
can do that
the great Michael Bisbee
what do you got oh my God spring has
sprung and our friends at manscape have
the best tools for some spring cleaning
folks they've already helped you tidy up
all the nooks and crannies of your
body's basement talking about your
wiener but this year manscape can help
you get the perfect presentation on that
beautiful face with the new beard hedger
Pro kit that's right if you notice of my
bear it doesn't look like a a print
Machinery out of ink anymore it's
looking fresh that's thanks to the beard
hedger Pro kit from manscape make sure
you look your best this spring by using
Code shop 20 that's seh ab20 to get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
it's time to tame your Mane with the
beard hedger Pro kit the sun is peeking
back out which means you'll have to show
your face in the daylight again so use
the kit to make sure your Scruff looks
award-winning whether you got the
Glorious beard floor or some smooth
Sleek cheeks like the mass cheeks all
right we got you covered man uh save 20
soft and free shipping with the coach 20
at manscape.com that's 20 soft and free
shipping with the code shop20 at
manscape.com all right focus on the face
and use the beard hedger Pro kit for the
cleanest look in the game manscaped
Flawless boom daddy that's a good artery
thanks dude you know yeah I'm gonna try
yours oh yeah and cheers
of course man whenever everybody
you're about to taste sweet nectar and
I've put there's literally my sweaters
in that bottle yeah you're just you're
gonna taste you won't taste the burn
it's smooth from the top to the bottom
Daddy
yo that really is man that's nice hey
that's good that's that Japanese wish
cheers bro thanks brother now hey that
really is [__] good that's nice I
know you know that but I'm like you know
you're trying to give like some
authentic opinion and reaction because
you never know the best one Logan tried
it and he goes oh thank God it's good
man I thought it's gonna be shitty I'm
like hey man he's like you never know I
try something you don't ever know so my
friend so many whiskey sometimes it's
shitty I'm like no I wouldn't come in
and bring you shitty whiskey and then
Bert we're the official supplier to Bert
kreischer's alcoholism he just [__]
drinks his stuff by the gallons yeah
this is incredible bro thanks brother
because you uh
into a Japanese yeah
because I'm not a big Japanese whiskey
fan no have you had some like hibiki and
stuff like that that's why it was like a
15-year aged uh what is it yeah
sometimes you get a little dicey yeah it
was just
it's spicy going it was spicy yeah I
thought I just thought it had too much
bite like the Japanese bite and that's
like real flowery but so when you're
doing this I was like I was like I
wonder how it'll be no because the
reason to me the Japanese make the
smoothest whiskey so that's why I wanted
that in there you know what I'm saying
no that is [__] good bro yep yep yep
brother that is doing it what so what's
uh when you come out here what's Taylor
doing
Taylor's actually going to be in Indy
tomorrow and cover the combine for the
combine yeah you've been watching it
could be no I haven't I've been keeping
up with like the highlights and stuff on
like you know they posted all the social
I don't dude I don't miss it really you
watch it 10 years in a row sometimes you
sit down and watch it every single
everything dude how about uh Nolan Smith
the other kid from Georgia yeah
I thought he was a backer they got them
they had him as a d-line but what yeah
they have them in the d-line category
but he would be what like a outside rush
I guess yeah probably which is where the
money's at freak Africa wasn't he he
wasn't he yeah yeah stupid I think I've
tweeted like I see well I'm not in the
league anymore
the way that they're making these guys
now dude it's [__] insane we watched
some kids yesterday when I was in The
Green Room I was doing shows and bread
we had the combine on some kid ran a
four two like eight you're just like you
know how rare that is
I was telling the comics and agreement
like no no you guys got to watch this
like yeah he runs fast lane four twos
yeah like you don't you don't understand
man and then that one comment goes has
anyone can can they run three sevens
like no get out absolutely three seven
shut the [__] are you [__] yeah
three seven God no but four four two
stupid dude I know you almost wish like
you could have saw like Dion or somebody
back in the day like the actual footage
to know you ever seen Chris Johnson's
yeah fast yeah cause yeah he's a Titan
he his record got broken right by um the
Washington kid that kid returner right
yeah who's that receiver
uh are you ever look him up yeah he went
to the do you go to the Raiders he was
already went to the Dallas Cowboys I
think but apparently he didn't have
Sticky Fingers because he could run out
[__] run everybody NFL Combine 40 you
know fast forward the fastest 40 at the
combine apparently he could catch the
Long Ball but then he struggled with
anything else imagine just yeah John
Ross John Washington and he went to I'm
pretty sure he went to the Raiders he
ran a 4-2-2
nutsos yeah we had uh Chris came on the
Pod he was a stud he was awesome Chris
Johnson yeah was he good yeah thunder
and lightning we had on uh Chris Johnson
and uh
Lindell white Oh Linda White's a
Colorado boy yeah for real yeah played
at East High School yeah he's a beast
you know like you know your Colorado
athletes oh do I ever man yeah now
you're in Colorado yeah yeah because I
saw your boy uh bo he was a Colorado guy
yeah yeah so I don't know I didn't I
wasn't aware I was kind of thinking like
is Brendan just biased yeah I'm a little
biased but he's the he's the real deal
yeah yeah he's the real [__] deal but
yeah uh yeah the guy went to Washington
he was a stud but yeah he had a problem
catch in the ball which is an issue in
the NFL yeah and he would do uh kick
returns and he's [__] he won a Super
Bowl last year
or this year Kansas City Chiefs 2023 and
he's President John Ross was oh it says
uh off-season or a practice squad member
only oh so you could have been on the
practice just get a ring
I think so I'd be asking for that ring
hell yeah I'd even pay for him like hey
you don't have to give it to me but I
was on the team can I get access to get
this right so so you're are you
officially done officially retiring uh
have you decided no I think it's like
it's one of those things to where you
don't like fully shut the door in case
like just the right situation of like
seven Will Compton jerseys which I love
by the way anytime I can sign to a team
I can always count on a text
but hey that Raider's one though that's
the daddy yes so like last year for
example I didn't plan on playing I plan
on pouring all in busting all that kind
of stuff because we got it we extended
with bar stool and they wanted me to
stand up a gambling show which I was
wanting to do you know because it's like
striking while they are on top I gotta
do it now if I know I'm not gonna play
yeah so we stood up at the bus and had a
gambling show well in the middle of the
year
Arthur Smith the head coach for the
Falcons he texted he was like we were
like bantering back and forth It's like
me big cat PFT and Arthur Smith all on a
group chat because they make fun of his
uh chin and stuff so he's like he text
me one more like hey put us on a group
chat so we're bantering about how
Falcons can win the Rams game if they
figure out a way to get Aaron Donald
tossed out of the game yeah and I was
like you just need to get somebody to
start a fight with him twerk and rip
their helmet off and just take one for
the team and let Aaron beat him with it
and somebody's like sounds like a job
for fullback Willy and art was like
where would you do that and I was like
oh I do I'll die for whatever it takes
he texts me on the side and I was like
hey are you in shape like could you play
I was like yeah give me a couple weeks
and nothing that tore it all in caffeine
because you get me throwing a workout
you know what I mean and he's like uh I
think we'll we'll have you in for a
workout I'm thinking we're still kind of
joking yeah because I'm saying that
toward all the caffeine I'm just like
making [__] up and um dude the next that
same day they call my agent my agent
calls her hey Atlanta wants to bring you
in for a workout I call Art of my hey
are you hey man I was kind of [__]
I've got the cleats on in seven months
yes
at that point they're in it they were in
the hunt Okay because he was thinking
about like you know the camaraderie the
juice like bring in a locker hell yeah
and uh he's like well how do you think
you're doing a workout I was like well I
was like let me get on the field today
and I'll call you back and tell you I
felt good moving around even though I
was sore as [__] the next day like don't
get into it she put the baby down for a
nap yeah I'm gonna go up to the football
field move around a little bit what are
you
albums you're all [__] hell yeah I
got it yeah I can do it hey I still feel
pretty good I did about four or five
reps and then can anybody cosign this no
no man but and he goes could you come
out I was like yeah let's go and then my
agent calls and he's like he goes
seriously what do you think I go I'm
gonna be honest and he goes you're not
[__] going out there because you get
hurt there's no risk and they're in he's
all you know the agent they're playing
full business game all that kind of
stuff so they call reschedule for two
weeks later I go in and crush the
workout two weeks later you have to run
a 40. no no nothing like that I'm
talking bro they took care of me in the
workout I told her I was like hey make
sure you give me them
Oklahoma there are a few guys in the in
the room with me and I'm like you
thinking are we all backers I was like
hey what's by you because if there's
enough of you you're all going to get a
break in between drills yeah you're
gonna go I'm gonna go yeah they were all
outside backers so I was by myself
you're the only middle back I was the
only middle backer they brought in to
work out everybody I'm talking there's
probably third there's probably 30 front
office people out there right they bring
the GM the president the Ops guy the
head coach the coaches the strength guys
they're all watching you work out and uh
and let me know when you got to start
introducing some of those guys and so I
started doing a workout we all kind of
coming in a little huddle before and I
kind of banter a little about my hey
make sure you know don't be afraid to
give me a water break yeah and they're
like oh don't worry anytime you need a
water break just let you know Susan know
and I was like Susan stay close I'm
telling you after everything after every
rep give me a drink of water and that
actually happened they like took care of
me but I killed the workout I did well
in the workout and he always still gots
it he he's like he brought I mean his
office and goes hey when would be ideal
for you to sign like perfect world will
confidence world what would you want to
have happen
and I was like are you being this is
unheard of yeah for listeners like yeah
unheard of this street because like a
[__] Brian earlier
no you got some Talent I'm just this on
Earth this is not but it's because our
we were at Tennessee together and we
just have a good relationship so he
trusts whatever he's like what are you
thinking because here's what we would be
able to do Dion Jones he had a backer
he's like he's going to be coming off IR
or something
he's like you know I think he'll he'll
be better suited in another system we're
not necessarily the best system for him
because he's a running head guy yeah and
um he's like but perfect world and I go
well
these next four weeks we're going to be
on the road doing the tailgate tour I
was like if we can get past November
12th the bus and bowl with Michigan
Nebraska we will have fulfilled our
Bojangles sponsorship gangster and I was
like honestly that would be perfect
world but if anything happens like
seriously I I don't want to miss the
opportunity because I would love to come
out here and play he like looked on his
computer scrolled down it was a Thursday
night game he's like we got a Thursday
night game he's like I think that'll
come for us we'll get you after that
next week damn it didn't happen next
week but the week after he goes hey pack
your truck we're gonna we're gonna make
this thing Shake damn and we went down
to sign and that's when the league
stepped in we sent in an amended
contract to say that I would separate
from all of gambling I would do all
these things in the NFL stepped in and
was like this is not enough we need him
to do X Y and Z was prepared to do X Y
and Z ultimately I personally this is
just my opinion I feel like they were
making it hard for me because of the
Barcelona conversation they hate the
bars because ultimately ultimately B I
would have had to separate even from
Boston's contract Jesus busting with me
and Taylor as an LLC
that's what I would have had to do and
I'm sitting there calling like guys
we've been in this deal since 2019 I've
been doing this yeah and they're like
well you know we'd have to see it's
because now you got bigger yeah yeah
yeah yeah more power and so by that time
a few weeks it went by because you know
when suits get involved everything moves
slower a few weeks went by Atlanta did
drop like three in a row they were kind
of out of the playoff hunt because we
went I wanted to play into the whole
playoffs make content and help busting
out hell yeah I was gonna go you know
how porno I know we're getting into this
yeah uh Jalen tell me about Turner and
gamrat so gamrat is a complete [__]
Savage he's the favorite on this it's a
good fight though it's number seven
verse number ten
um it's a really really good fight great
fight this whole card is stacked who do
you think's gonna win this one camera
yeah 100 camera
all of them are savages this is the best
card in the hospital yeah there have
been a lot of people like on social talk
about how this car is about to be listed
it's so good so uh we're the odds on
their chin so you got gamrat at minus
185. I feel you'd be a little higher
even though Jalen Turner is a beast and
he's tall for the division
and then next is next we have uh Neil
versus uh that shaft
what did you see this uh shaft cat
monster he's 16-0 eight submissions
eight Knockouts he'll be your champ he's
a minus 460 favorite for a reason both
cards [__] great though but so now
gamrod is he young is he is he a guy
that's climbing like Fast kind of like
oh he's a real he's a real badass like
real
Savvy badass
um so so back to that so obviously the
NFL has a you know bit of a thing up
their ass for you and busting with the
boys and Barstool in general so it just
didn't work out yeah it just didn't work
once the few weeks happened because in
uh in the NFL you need three games to
get accredited season and since there
were like two or three games left it
almost just didn't make sense because I
wouldn't have got the 10th credited year
to have Push toward benefits and uh you
know again I wanted to get down there to
where we actually had a shot at going to
the playoffs because I just wanted to be
a part of a squad hell yeah could make a
play yeah and then like we had stuff
lined up to make content like you know
how Dave does the uh one bite the pizza
stuff yeah I was gonna review because
since Atlanta is known for strip clubs I
was going to review the strip club food
are you gonna call me Magic City
you get the wings you get the the Lou
Williams Wings because I play in Atlanta
I'm in Atlanta in April and I play the
punch line every time I go there I don't
go to the strip club I uh Postmates from
the strip club their food that's a good
their food that's amazing it's the best
wings I've ever had in your life now
here's the thing it's gonna hurt the
pocket I heard me and the boys for the
boys over those Lou Williams Wings which
he actually went and got wings and got
kicked out of the remember he got spent
by the NBA for getting the wings which
he went at me on Twitter for that he
said what the [__] man keep pushing this
narrative I'm like dude that's what
happened you got you went into the strip
because you got wings that's called Lou
Williams wings so I was like I'm doing
my part now so I'm in Atlanta with the
boys we've done with the show I'm like
I'm gonna get those wings like we're
going to strip club I'm like absolutely
not my girl would kill me what we're
gonna do is we're gonna Postmates it 170
dollars for 40 wings no [__] I'm not
playing around but it man was it worth
it and I got the [__] uh pork chops
too remember those pork chops Jay yeah I
mean I was finger looking good I was
licking the the [__] box dude so good
so this is the strip club food in
Atlanta is we're talking about for
anywhere
in Denver probably don't eat the rib eye
but uh Magic City in Atlanta whatever
they have it's like five star dining
so you go there just to eat then you
just if it happens to be a fat ass break
yeah you know that place is legendary
that's where like two chains that's
where yeah Magic City I think is
featured a little trip was featured in
like every song my boy has the best
picture of all time Adam right now
here's a picture he's with Lil Wayne and
Rick Ross and he holds the picture he
holds the camera like this professor
photographer holds camera like this
snaps it and it's strippers and the they
put so much money out their faces are
cut they're standing up and he stand up
you can just see like barely his head
it's all cash in the room it's like a
small room just filled with cash
it's like it's like you drop [__]
guppy fish in my fish tank just
some horny boys out there bro
Rampage
what up dog
right there man
hey they're not chain is filthy
sorry I'm late my cousin fault how do
you do
I thought he won but uh that means he
lost no no I don't know I left I I had
to go oh you didn't even wait for the
judge to scorecard I didn't but I think
that's why I love you two out of three
three rounds he he's piecing them up
yeah yeah he's the amateur uh what
weight class
but his opponent didn't even make weight
so he's so he best fighter heavyweight
yeah that's amateur [__] yeah they have
rap they have uh like shin guards on and
[__] yeah what I miss what I miss you
missed bow nickel absolutely mopping the
floor with some poor Jimmy Pickett he
twists his dick off live on air he's
twisting dicks on air like Kobayashi
Twisted in his mouth is that is that in
the rules now is that a new new move
yeah I think so yeah dick twisting what
you need man hey I want some crouching
thick tiger
you already know
these are my twists and dicks you did
you wash your hands while you touching
it I know that dog
washing hands what are you pretty afraid
of coven no I'm Just a Dream freak
yeah this is my favorite stuff right
here gotcha that [__] is good it is good
that [__] really is good thanks brother
so uh Rampage is very coming in so
um will has played 10 Seasons or not
credit 10 seasons Nine season in the NFL
play at Nebraska he's my boy right does
his own podcast blown up by some other
boys
Nashville we have a bus oh [__] that no
we'll take care of you well if you're
out there or you know he's oh he's he's
all over the place you know what I am
going to be in Memphis
um May 13th because you know I'm with
the UFL that new MMA League they're
going to be there I'm with him too
brother I'm with them too what's up
daddy what's up man what's this UFL it's
a new Fight League it's like for the
fighters yeah yeah what do you mean by
foreign
no the fighters yes
damn how dope is that one of your eyes
different from a different color I don't
think so all right I'm just I guess that
tiger thick yeah yeah yeah I ain't even
accept it yet not him he said his eyes
changing color so uh back to so then are
you so this season of Team One signing
here that's kind of what this is what
I'm afraid this one I'm afraid for you
right you see a wife and kid we know
football's not healthy God bless you you
made it to the NFL if you played nine
years long and I played I played
literally a cappuccino with Buffalo
Bills and they were not as friendly as
the Atlanta Falcons were friendly to you
they were literally like can we pay you
not to mention that you were here like
why but um so you have all this stuff
going on man you got what every athlete
anybody on Atlanta Falcons any team he
played for they would kill to have what
you have right now and then you're gonna
sacrifice all that to what play one or
two more years you know what I'm saying
it's not so you gotta buy the nuts right
it would be mostly to get in kind of the
same a similar situation with Atlanta if
you get to the end of the year to where
the pads are off you're not practicing
in pads anymore not being yourself
you're doing walkthroughs like I didn't
go like you gotta I finesse the last
four training camps just by you got the
podcast and then I wait to get on
because the injury rate's 100 in the NFL
100 so you know a backer is going to go
down all you just need you just need a
guy who can run and Tackle yeah but if
you so if you wait to end the season for
busting with the Bros and supposed to
start covering the playoffs you cover
the Super Bowl so you can miss that you
know what I'm saying Miss what bus with
the boys yeah covering that stuff so
then you sacrifice that well but still
like it's it's established enough to
where you could play into all the
content of it yeah it's in saying that
it's like if there's an NFL team listen
it's like oh it's heads in it for the
wrong reasons at this point it's just
like it would be the move of of just
creating content to keep that stuff
moving and literally just being a role
player like it was like Hey I want you
coming I want you to Mentor the young
guys yeah you don't know if you need it
I want you I want you to cover something
like the brands there bro I'm feeling
Taylor Taylor all that [__] all that
Taylor's All Pro I got one question go
ahead hey I'm honored for this question
by the way are you gonna be honest
though maybe
is the NFL scripted
I've been watching tick tocks now
you saw you saw here in Foster
no I didn't see that one you saw you're
about to talk about it and we allowed to
bring the videos and stuff up no we do
that YouTuber kick us off uh haters but
Aaron Foster came out what did he do on
PFT yeah micro dosing yeah he was
macroducing shrooms it was like yo that
felt scripted everybody everybody gets a
script but he was just joking joking
around yeah bro they sold that [__] so
well so well even the even the big media
played into it well by being like Oh
it's scripted and then they obviously
talk about the humor and then I tried
trolling it obviously we all know it's a
joke if you watch it I tried drawing
like I get yeah you called it bad you
said you yeah you played against it for
a minute I was like for that reason I'm
into it I played into it being like I
played into it riding with Aaron Foster
who I love I absolutely love him he's a
monster and we've talked he's great I
thought you were saying all this is you
guys are trying to validated why are you
no I'm ballad dancing weak no like going
in leaning into like hey man come on bro
be cool don't don't out that it's
scripted oh that's what you're doing
yeah
bro if there's anything scripted I would
have zero [__] clue oh for real they
ain't give me no you know what the only
reason only reason I was thinking that
because I heard that um it's classified
as entertainment like the WWE that
that's why I wanted to lean into why I
would be scripted because they are an
entertainment first business so if if um
something's class that's about
entertainment you can legally script it
yeah but wouldn't it is UFC probably
registered as an entertainment business
I don't know I don't know are all sports
League
I heard I don't know for sure I heard
this there were some great memes that
came out because they they had one they
said uh who was it oh they said uh uh
Ray Lewis reading his script for 2006
things
[Laughter]
you can't believe none you see on Tick
Tock now because but part of it Rampage
outside because you went on a podcast I
may have been Adam 22 I forget who it
was and you were saying that uh Pride
was some of it's scripted oh yeah some
some [__] someone to fight some problems
so will so Pride was like for sure I
remember MMA fans is like the Golden Age
of fighting for sure Rampage came out
they got Ricardo Rona you got Shogun
ninja Fedor Crow cop yeah
I remember that I could keep going yeah
but but a lot of it to your point A lot
of it was it'd be like Merkel crocop
versus like a Japanese wrestling
literally the wrestlers doing a scripted
thing otherwise you can get his [__]
head kicked but not but not but not
every time I followed a couple pro
wrestlers and it wasn't scripted but
some of the fights there were scripted
for you no no I've never done a scripted
fight but um they asked me when I fought
sakaraba you know saying they it was
like a last minute fight I only got ten
thousand dollars for the fight right
Jesus I was training I was gonna fight
Ken Shamrock and I had like enough time
to get rid of the kitchen rocking but
they but soccer Robin came so I said
[__] Ken Shamrock because that was only
five thousand yeah and so I was okay
I'll go take the ten thousand two weeks
blah blah blah go and then I get to
Japan and um they was like um I don't
know how to come say you started but it
was like uh if you um lose by knockout
or if you go to sleep or don't tap you
get uh uh 11 11 000 I was like uh but
what if I knock him out they said ten
thousand dollars that's it
but what if he knocks me out you get
eleven thousand dollars
yeah a thousand dollars I'm not doing
this or two thousand I can't remember so
yeah it was not a lot of money not a lot
it wasn't worth it it wasn't worth it
and I ain't gonna lie back in those days
I was grind I was I was grinding because
I left everything to be a fighter you
could have used the cash I needed it so
if they were like ten thousand if you
knock his ass out hundred thousand if in
the third round
especially back then that was cash too
yeah and I and at that time in my life I
ain't never even had a hundred thousand
dollars in my pocket yeah in my hand
never seen I get it I would have thought
about it but that's why when Rampage is
scripted like some of those back now the
UFC everyone's like yo what if UFC is so
I don't feel like I feel like boxing
boxes boxes scripted in a different ways
different way from the judges standpoint
boxing is scripted like this where the
journeyman they know that they're the
[__] journeyman yes that's why I
scripted like they some of them go out
there and try to win but it's like they
already feeding the head like I'm a
journey man I'm not supposed to win this
right and so that's why you see a lot of
boxers like 30-0 35-0 because you look
at their record and and they fought a
bunch of Journeymen MMA is the most
unscripted uh Sport and like straight up
we we don't we don't play [__] like UFC
don't play that [__] no that's right
yeah they did CM Punk would be working
on the Rivalry with you and Chuck was
scripted no [__] [__] no I think it
[Laughter]
as soon as I threw that water I was
trying to get out of room and I opened
up the door and remember that little
bench that's right yeah the door bounced
back and like counted
yeah is that a honeycomb door bro that
was it that was it was a real thing it
was cardboard inside yeah yeah it cut me
that mother would come I head butted it
yeah everyone's like that was fake I'm
like no it was not yeah your guy's [__]
was real it was it was almost so much
animosity like it was sucked for the
fighters because we were like trying to
train and they're like like literally
that was back when it was like first
started like getting a lot of traction
and stuff
you were in your Prime I was the first
coach to come back for a second season
uh Real Talk how mad was Richard we put
those shitty chickens in his car so mad
and I was like brother chickens chill no
we we fed them a whole bunch of [__]
and then who painted then then who
painted the room pink remember that I
think Tiki did that [__] yeah and I
remember like you know it takes a lot to
get under my skin I mean I was like I
don't give a [__] I'll train your pink
room and I had to train in a pink room
and they were like so mad I was gonna
give a [__] dude they're paying the room
pink and that was the one that you were
on yeah yeah as a fighter right the
fighter yeah yeah Rampage was opposite
yeah so I fought against Rampages too
but he him and one other person there's
only two people I got along with yeah me
and Rampage with friends yeah we was
cool yeah who was who's the other one on
you is it McSweeney McSweeney yeah yeah
there's only two of them I got along
with everybody else we was like it was
it was tension everywhere
yes people since that's the best season
bro Oh by far yeah I like to think it
was maybe I think it's you ready Paige
and Kimbo yeah keep this massive I'm I'm
gonna have to say Tiki like brought a
lot to the table because he's one that
did a lot of the pranks T's smart he's
smart with this right Tiki smart but
that that it became super scripted where
the seasons because they did that out of
just [__] around like [__] each
other and then like when Brian Ortega I
forget the other fighter was on it was
like kind of like it got weird like the
pranks got weird oh for real like they'd
walk out and the rims would be off his
car you know all right it's like all
right yeah yeah it's like yeah you
didn't do that in an hour yeah people
love that uh Kimbo one too though yeah
people loved him when he was actually
coming in coming from the backyard and
coming into the he was the man of the
five game yeah everybody wanted him I
was so glad I got him on my team I
really wanted them on my team but I
don't think Rashad wanted him on his
team because he wasn't like good in Jiu
Jitsu and all that stuff can't wrestler
but you know I know the power of you
know reality TV so you know my my main
goal is all ways to entertain the fans
yeah you know what I'm saying because
that's why I said you were such a star
yeah I like entertaining so I I I'm not
a coach I knew I had a hard time like
would you allow your coaches to coach
yeah yeah
this is this a good fight though yeah
it's a good fight get around to Savage
now he lost his last fight
I said we haven't really watched any of
it but yeah that's how the show goes
yeah we don't have to pay attention just
bantering and [__] drinking with each
other would you ever get in there and
fight
I dabble now Rampage he wants to do uh
Power slap leak he said oh okay you
should try that yeah whenever I get done
is that weight classes yeah yeah yeah
hey can I stop a [__]
did you get in it hey here's a good
question this is a good question for
what we were talking about earlier the
time in your life you were talking about
on pride and talking about you didn't
really have cash and stuff like that
would you have done something like a
slap League get a few thousand dollars
yeah [__] yeah
something stranger you know what I'm
saying
something strange
[Laughter]
he's gonna have their hands full if a
transgender oh yeah gets in that [__]
oh yeah used to be Brad now she's Becky
yeah slapping [__] we have a real
problems are they doing females in the
slap oh yeah dude where's knockout was
that this girl and she's pretty too but
she's kind of built and she was like
yeah I'm just here to have a good time
she slap this girl so [__] bad she
did a front flip popped up fell back
down and it was just it's just it was
like that was that's how the public got
introduced I want to see that [__] then
some dude got slapped so hard he just
had an aneurysm like his face was just
like [__] up for the rest of the day
it was to the side
and he still won though yeah yeah I know
I saw that one what do you think about
it though you Dana's getting behind you
think it's going to do you think it's
going to take yeah it's already taken
yeah no it's this is it one one hitter
quitter no I think you're gonna live no
it's gonna Live on YouTube yeah
yes yeah yeah he'll get abused and they
get Tick Tock views obviously it's not
going to be like like as a league no
it's not gonna live yay combines would
you do would you would you do back in
the day would you do the snap absolutely
not I don't think so I mean if you would
ask if you got cut from what uh buffalo
buffalo you got cut from Buffalo right
when they cut you you get a call a few
thousand bucks no man I don't we gotta
we got an invitation but don't get paid
much though no two grand okay okay 50
grand for a slap I don't think so no
don't think about the average now you're
rich as [__] man it's kind of hard
I guess I would yeah
[Music]
behind him making sure they don't hit
their head more it's insane you got this
man
I mean it's like you got to win the coin
toss you gotta try to go first you see
Bigfoot Silva took a picture of his hand
he's like yo slap fight like what's up
like who the [__] that's why I don't
think I would do something because I
ain't got big hands like like you gotta
have some awareness did you see the dude
who's the MMA fighter he had like
whatever three fights but Daniel was
like this guy's MMA fighter so he
probably can hit but he had a little
sugar in his tank and he was all hey
it's hard at all hey that's what was up
they got knocked out
the Rampage is a cross on yeah random
HRS I [__] Cannon he does he stands
down like it's over it's some of the
guys get slapped and they're like yeah
bring him like this dude got some screws
yeah I don't blow out the eardrum
yeah that's a nasty when the girls love
each other this [__] is not I get how
why it's just dumb and barbaric but
that's like the entertainment factor
it's like I go to World Star Hip-Hop for
that yeah I don't go to TBS do you still
go to Worldstarhiphop every morning
really every morning I watch all this
[__] out from the uh World Star Hip Hop
Instagram didn't it uh probably why yeah
because I feel like I don't see a whole
lot I'm not really on Instagram like
that so I go literally worldstar.com
Instagram I watch the shootings like
it's always in Brazil or Venezuela so
I'm getting shot in the head at a barber
shop I'm like how's this [__] Bro
Twitter starting to bring that stuff out
there's this profile called fight Haven
and they just show the craziest [__] Bro
oh somebody can be crazy sometimes
yeah yeah I'm sitting there looking at
the stuff I'm like man why are we even
putting this I saw some Brazilian cartel
just shoot this girl in the face oh my
God Sunday morning yeah I'm with my kids
Brazil they just they they doing a whole
bunch of [__] up [__] I saw I saw a
[__] evil parade they did I'm I'm
disappointed just a whole parade of
evils yeah it was just evil as [__] I I
was so disappointed because I thought um
Brazil was like a religious you know
country they are they'll cut each
other's heads off yeah yeah on their way
to kill Yeah man they got the devil like
in the parade and doing demons and I saw
what the [__] is Brazil doing I'm
disappointed in that yeah you know
sometimes you thought Brazil had it
together I thought they had it together
you ever been to the favelas I've seen
them [__] but it's kind of
together like I went there when I fought
in Brazil and I was doing promo I went
to the favels because I was like hey am
I good there like you're good because
they respect you and you're not trying
to get any drugs nothing and we drive up
to favelas it's like it's different than
the United States like Hollywood Hills
the most expensive real estate you can
get Brazil favel's in the Hills cheapest
so they're all stacked on each other
yeah like tents yeah but when you go by
it's dudes of the AK-47s just mean
mugging you but I came to give the kids
like shin guards and rash guards and
like fight gear because they love to
fight so it was great I had a great time
these little dudes were throwing [__]
flying triangles in the dirt and [__]
then give a [__] no shoes wow no water
that's good I said a bunch of Gears
great at such a good time you saw the uh
you saw that video in St Louis
of that dude who shot that homeless guy
right there on the street no yes bro
literally loaded the gun right there in
front of this homeless man did you see
it yeah
and they just shot him yo he literally
loaded the gun the dude's like the
dude's like sitting on the ground and
this dude he's clearly like jeffed up or
whatever he's like loading the gun and
these people like inside the door or
maybe around the corner
filming a little bit you just puts it
puts a gun in his head and [__]
shoots him and that's was all yeah I was
going all around yeah this past week he
got dealt with I'm sure oh I'm sure he
did yeah Jesus Christ man what's wrong
with him but I'm saying those videos
like they're they're out there but
they're putting them out there on
Twitter and everything like that [__]
will break your heart and then the
beating like the the upload like the
bully beatings on like in high school
bro it's like who fights like that now
nobody got knocked out when you were
growing up no one really got like all
the time like there would be a chance
where like I'd see my brother like
Atlanta Shawna kid I'm like damn he's
kind of wobbled he got his Bell run yeah
now they don't stop till somebody gets
knocked out and nobody's breaking the
fights out because they're off yeah yeah
that's dangerous it's not good it's
dangerous you got a lot of fights in
high school oh yeah
[Music]
have been in over a thousand fights if I
could do math because I'm breaking down
and tell you what I got a cousin
God Rest Your Soul now he's six months
younger than me and my mama said me and
him been fighting since we was in
Pampers damn and his mom is my mom's
niece
and they're the same age you know it's
kind of weird because my family's old
yeah and so me and him almost like same
age six months apart so we grew up
really close together and we fought
almost every day Jesus Christ who's when
do you remember he beat me up one time
damn why is he coming back for 99. he
was a heart he was a hard-headed but he
was like he was like the he's a
journeyman yeah but but he could he
could fight a little bit but he just he
was just like um I came he was like the
a hard-headed [__] he did not
learn he just got he grew up in a
project down the street for me and we we
grew up like at my grandmother's house
and he lived in the projects and it was
like it was woods from my house to his
house we had a path in the woods I could
run to his house he'd run in my house so
we hung out she has were best friends
yeah we're cousins like we hung out all
the time what was that but he was
stealing my [__] he stood my clothes
still there still that and and sometimes
people would bullying him and I would
and I would stick it up for him I stick
up for him go fight for him but then I
get jumped and he won't help me I'm
fighting two or three [__] and
he's sitting there watching then after I
get jumped and I beat his ass do you
think that's because he can't fight he
wasn't as good as fighter as me yeah but
he could fight but he wasn't he just he
was like he was terrible then he joined
a gang the GDs then I kick his ass from
joining the game
or no no he didn't get out and that's
how he passed away no no he he changes
right if he grew up he changed his life
but a couple years ago you know my
family owned construction companies and
um I don't have my family name so if you
don't have your family name they kind of
use you as like laborers and [__] yeah
so he was um he was wanting to learn how
to operate the Machinery if you don't
have a family name you really they
really don't teach you how to operate
the auto Machinery yeah they said that
for the fans yeah
that's where the money's at it yeah so
he get on the [__] steam the steam
roller yeah and he flipped that
[__] and they told him don't get
back on there he was so slow yeah but he
don't know what he don't he didn't know
what the [__] he's doing he's on the
side of the Hill he flipped it right
yeah then he get back on it again the
next day and he flipping and crushed his
head yeah I'm still mad at him for [__]
he killed himself for being hard-headed
that's how he's always yeah I mean he's
one in 99 and fighting yeah well he won
some fights but he only won 1999 he beat
me one time I slipped and he he mounted
he mounted me out and I didn't know Jiu
Jitsu back then yeah I was probably like
at this time I was probably like 10 11
years old and he and he got and I never
I never admitted that he beat me up but
after he passed away I went out here
together like yeah it sounds like you
still can't admit that you that you
didn't slip all right you said what it
sounds like you didn't slip no I did
sleep I wouldn't let nobody kick my ass
yeah I took Pratt I took pride in my
fight that's a bummer he passed away
though I know it [__] me up
Steamroller Steamroller man so when you
lost it was always when you were
outnumbered I I love some fights because
I used to fight grown men too I lost I
lost some fights I just fight grown man
as a kid yeah yeah can we talk about
your cousin's uh off-roading in the
steamroller though that's insane he was
like going up the hills no no it's like
a um like a bank like a oh and it was
just like that it was like this that he
wrote and he wrote it and then my uncle
told him don't get back on there you
don't know what you're doing you're not
qualified to do it his dumb ass got back
on it the next day I'm still you know
what he had though heart yeah you know
what I'm saying like you whooped his ass
a thousand times yeah we Steamroller
fell off it sounds like a lot of the
losses though he wasn't even here he
wasn't trying to fight he's like oh you
didn't [__] help me please just broke
my hand I broke my finger up a cutting
them one time never never forget that
fight he was star fights with me knowing
he he's going to get his ass kicked yeah
he will steal my clothes knowing if I
found out I was going to beat his ass my
mom said we fought almost every day 365
days in a year and we grew up with each
other fighting every day we fought
almost every day almost every day and if
I wasn't fighting him he was getting
beat up by people in the projects you'd
have to fight I had to go on and [__]
and then I kick his ass for not helping
me kick those dudes ass that's why you
got all your experience oh yeah yeah
when that with your amateur first
average right there is one amateur fight
the [__] he does this guy has 3 000
amateur fights all right you're
sandbagging I I at least I had at least
a thousand fights in my life because I
used to hate bullies right yeah so I
usually all the time who the [__] was
trying to bully you deal they wasn't
bullying me they was bullying my friends
[__] and my brother among your friends
like you know especially if they knew it
was Rampage because we live right down
the street from the for the projects and
they the project kids were harder than
the kids in my neighborhood yeah we had
this one kid in my neighborhood named
Ralph okay uh I think Ralph just passed
away not to go now damn another
steamrolling accident no no no no no no
man my most of my friends didn't make it
bro most of them did most of them didn't
make it to 16. gang banging all
different type of [__] yeah breakfast is
Memphis is different yeah if they start
robbing each other I couldn't understand
it when I moved away to uh Raleigh it
was where I started wrestling [__] I
hear all these stories they started Rob
they grew up together they started
robbing each other and [__] because
they're awesome dope and [__] right
there right but this one kid ref he uh
was really weak everybody used to beat
his ass and I used to feel real he was a
big kid like an overweight chubby kid
you know one of those real soft soft
soul and then he he started hanging
around with this other dude named Kiki
that was uh a family friend and his mom
actually named me and he's Kiki and he
in jail for murder now damn
they're fired back he he murdered it's
different story so but Kiki was like a a
real bad influence him and raps are
Robin [__] and Raph turned tough but he
was he was a [__] he was a [__] yeah
but he now he's going to jail and stuff
like that he's doing all this [__] and
then you know he grew up and trying to
be tough tough now because he he got
influenced by Kiki yeah trying to prove
himself and I prove himself and then
then he [__] in and out of jail and
stuff like that then I think somebody
killed him damn
who gave the nickname Rampage my cousin
Tyrone
eight eight years old eight years old
what a great name for an eight-year-old
yeah what a [__] yeah you know some
name that sticks yeah you remember that
video game Rampage yeah I used to play
that I used to play a video game great
game and I have a horrible movie I'm the
nicest guy on the planet but I have the
worst temper like when I lose my temper
I get it's a tough man I get unlimited
strength man even today you have a bad
temper yeah but I know how to control it
more now because you're older and I grow
older more mature and then she sent me
to jail a couple times yeah
yeah man I went to I went to jail man in
college um just one of my teammates
tried to um one of my teammates hit me
in the mouth with a with a payphone
and I tried to kill him you tried to
kill him that's right where'd you go to
college yeah yeah Lassen Junior College
to wrestle the wrestle yeah damn yeah it
was self-defense uh were you a stud
wrestler no I sucked I started at 17. I
sucked
before weight class uh 170 171 then I
wrestled one 177's in college
oh so you wrestled in college too yeah I
only won one Rescue Mission card but
that helped you with your MMA career
because at least you had the
fundamentals where you could get on the
feed especially back then yeah you think
so for him not being good at wrestling
he was going into practice at a college
level so he's getting the takedown
defense the basics yeah you don't need
to have a high level wrestling in order
to stop but take that right yeah because
because I'm thinking like growing up I
was I was okay or I was Solitaire
wrestling Cody my younger brother he was
a senior national champ coming out oh
damn okay but I'm thinking like when
he's like would you go on the doctor I'm
thinking myself I mean I've never done
the whole throwing hands background so I
have no clue how it's fair in it yeah
and it's like if you're not if you
weren't good at wrestling growing up I'm
just curious how you feel like that
would carry over into helping him in his
MMA because with his fire because you're
just not you know you know what I mean
what happened I was strong I was always
strong and I was a defensive wrestler my
um first year started and I went
undefeated all the way to a regional
finals and then they some guy beat twice
they decided to give him the match so if
you would have told me like if Rampage
was young music man I wasn't very good
at wrestling and my goal in New York
City is take guys down I'm like probably
not for you but if he's like I just want
to stand and bang and avoid the takedown
he has the fundamentals we can avoid the
takedown gotcha from all that wrestling
experience it's gonna be a problem which
it was even if you're not a good
wrestler oh yeah yeah obvious yeah yeah
I'll beat some Olympic wrestlers yeah
advice you know I can wrestle I just I
just wasn't really good I got my
wrestling got better as I started doing
MMA and that's the reason why I actually
started doing MMA to get back and
wrestling got you because I got injured
in college and the college just threw me
away bro yeah they didn't take me to the
hospital Cutthroat man because it's a
business it threw me away and I had to
heal I had to let it heal up on his on
his own what was the mascot at that
school
[Music]
when you're in the county in high school
it's probably them same ones that are
always like a mountain lion or something
there's always mountain lions and [__]
up there it was in the mountains this
this dude yeah
I like cougars hell yeah yeah
cougars are cool cougars are fun
if they keep themselves up hell yeah hey
hey they got a job Asian cougar hey
are there a lot of Asian cougars though
[__] yeah I used to work at a Vietnamese
bar when I first moved that you were
just please
not like my black ass
I said you're definitely gonna find the
Asians at uh Vietnamese oh you're going
to find some Asians but they were
feeling the black guy they wouldn't fit
in the black guy they were like who else
means two black people no they think
your dick too big oh yeah you right girl
bro I started lying I'm like it ain't
true it ain't true it ain't that big you
have to go the opposite they're not
small yeah yeah [__] around and find out
yeah
this is a great fight though uh Neo
versus uh freaking uh Rashad Evans
shopcot is a this shot he's 18 and uh
160 eight submissions eight Knockouts he
beat Neil magni this is like his I don't
Neil Magazine's a big test this is
another big test for him he missed
weight though and he's a big Underdog he
should probably get [__] up the shop
cat's a the real deal real real deal you
know you're in trouble when you're
fighting a guy that wears those fuzzy
hats like khabib Wares oh yeah he wears
one of those oh yeah scary why did he
wear is he trying to cut off khabib or
is this is his culture too okay where's
where's he from with that name I call
him Cat Daddy but his his real name's uh
shove cat
no
this guy used to work was it Uzbekistan
Uzbekistan I don't know where that's at
but um this guy used to work at a Texas
Roadhouse
as up uh two years ago you swear you
know fire the Texas Roadhouse uh muffins
are the biscuits are [__] oh yeah yeah
with their with the butter yeah yeah
what's the uh you know what's overrated
is that uh what is it called the onion
blossom or the
Blossom's Roadhouse right no this is oh
no oh is that Chili's awesome blossoms
no it ain't chili I don't think it's
Chili's I think it's one of these
steakhouses I think well that'd be
Outback Outback the Awesome Blossom that
[__] that shit's overrated I feel like a
lot of people love the uh the the
blossom yeah the Blossom on you yeah a
lot of people with bad taste a lot of
people I think I think he's khabib's
cousin I don't think so man he looks
Asian though yeah yeah that part of the
world is Mongolian yeah a lot of um
because Genghis Khan raped so many
people that he spread his seed all over
the place right these are this is
history right oh you're being serious
yeah no no he's true that's why there's
a big Asian influence like like you'll
see a Russian like you ain't rushing
that's a [__] Mongolian yeah right I
read if you got uh B blood type you
probably a descendant of Genghis Khan
yeah like he he raped like people left a
million people at a time yeah he spread
a seed everywhere yeah damn I didn't
know he didn't care
of the population in his Time Savage
Savage first person to uh ride horses
like it he was the one who was like we
need to get on these [__] horses yeah
and then they would they would go
through like the the winner in the
deserts and stuff and they didn't have
any you know water or anything they
would kill a horse and drink its blood
to survive Savage Savage yeah it's some
yeah different levels yeah
yeah so you speak of evil parade
yeah that's the evil spread do you know
could be personally no I don't met him a
few times his first fight was I fought
on the same card yeah I think one of his
first fights I think it was on the card
I think I met him in Japan
um the last Bellator and was he cool
yeah he was cool but I I I I really like
didn't pay that much attention because
um he he blocked me on Instagram I don't
even [__] know him weird it could be
blockchain yeah yeah because when when
he fought um uh Conor McGregor I was
trying to um you know congratulate or do
something tag him I couldn't like what
the [__] I couldn't do I wonder why he
would block you and I had never but I
don't think he runs a social media I
thought his manager Ali does have you
had an issue with Ali no my manager
probably had it yeah so that's why
I would assume who knows it could be I
guarantee kabir's a good dude yeah
really good dude you think he comes back
no absolutely not no he promises daddy
never fight again
how's his Eagle
um show doing he stopped doing it he
retired from MMA I don't know but he he
he had his fight lead he stopped doing
it he's out he's done with MMA he's like
I'm not Corning guys no more am I right
on that Jay
uh so I fought
165 and he fought where's he at on that
liner he was the first my bad he was the
first fight on the main card he fought
Pat Healy one of this decision Jay found
this yeah yep
so yeah I was the third fight on the
pay-per-view Jon Jones fought gusvin
which is the greatest fight of all time
at light heavyweight
brow Eddie Weiland than me now here's
the thing I hate to rain on John's
parade here but I was on the cover of
the Toronto newspaper not Jon Jones for
choking out Matt Mitchell nice yeah
slight Flats yeah that's a good one uh
Rampage how do you think John does
tonight at heavyweight have you first of
all before you answer have you seen the
pictures of his heavyweight body yeah
boy
big boy the Vietnamese girls would not
like his thickness they will not know in
any capacity you know you know who Jon
Jones look like right now have you ever
seen that uh that TV show Supergirl
you haven't seen the TV show not even
once what's it on I don't know it's wbcw
so what's the name of that I don't even
think I get it it's a black guy owner
his name brother ain't nobody John as
well he's like
CW with the Frog still
WWB this guy yeah that guy oh that's the
guy from uh uh True True Blood
you think he looks like him yeah this is
what I thought when I saw John Jones
where I said oh a little bit I can see
how you see that you think he's winning
tonight oh they look different wait they
had to borrow her but I'll go back to it
this is what I think I won't be
surprised if Jon Jones get knocked the
[__] out I won't be surprised well he
did get hit in his last three fights at
like heavy right because some people
think he lost two of those five right
and John Jones haven't fought in what
three or three years three years yeah so
it's gonna be a lot of rust but he's
going to out Wrestle game come on that's
the thing like but there's my caveat
here if it was anybody else like guns
never fought a Grappler ever in his
entire career they gave him the path to
get the title he's never found a grapple
the best grapple he fight is a guy named
Francis Ghana who can't wrestle maybe a
blue belt and Francis took him down with
one leg he had torn MCL ACL took him
down beat him be a decision
John can grapple his ass off now the
caveat to that is John in his last five
fights no takedown attempts for real
nope didn't take down anybody didn't
even try those fights we like kind of
lost against Donald Reyes we got Santos
never even attempted a takedown I wonder
why that is but knowing that you're
about to go against God here aren't you
probably in your Camp working yeah I
would say in the first round he takes
him down and uh tkos him with elbows but
wouldn't you say like with gone wouldn't
there's not enough hours
in the day to catch up to John Joe no
there's not enough hours John Jones is
uh but I feel like you're kind of saying
that though based on again three years I
feel like the three years thing is what
three years and going up a weight class
it's a lot that's awesome but also and I
know I've trained with John Jackson's
for for you for a number of years he
only trained with heavyweights beat the
[__] out of us and I'm talking I won't
say their names like top 10 like former
world champion guys who do shark shark
tank rounds where you know what shark
tank is he stays in and then a fresh guy
Avery round rotates in on him so it gets
worse and worse and worse and he would
Molly [__] the [__] out of all this big
name guys well-known guys beat the [__]
out of us we going like what the [__]
and he'd be I don't know coming from a
bar or some [__] I was in there warming
up Pinnacle condition hydrated he'd get
dehydrated just put his gloves on not
warm up and mop the floor with us all of
us but again that's back in the day true
yeah true it's back in there yeah so but
if he's even a version of that this easy
fight for him now if he's just
doing it to come back and have the
layoff and has to prove something
himself gone is no punk he's the most
athletic heavy we've had in a long time
like John can fight yeah yeah but the
other thing is gone never photographer
he's not a knockout artist he's more of
a technician like he knocked out you
know uh to avasa and black beast but
those guys came towards him he knocked
out uh Santos or Junior dos Santos but
again those guys are the aggressor if
you're if you're not going to aggress
aggress that guy he'll sit back he's
fine just point smart he has really good
footwork he's a beast man has a Godsmack
tattoo he don't knock people out with
his hands though no no John's on
knockout artists either that's why I
think John takes down he either submits
him or he goes them like first two
rounds
yeah that's you thinking if he's even a
version of his old self yeah if he's
even like a fraction like off a little
bit if he shows it like show up against
Tom Graves he can get [__] up that's
what I'm saying even with the Reyes
fight his last one it's not like he
looked that good now you didn't look
good but the thing is like he's used to
finding Rampage Jacks in the world Leo
machidas Chael sonens uh Vitor Bell for
Gusman DC like all these huge names and
then all right here's Anthony Smith who
love Anthony but he's not a legend like
those guys here's Dominic Reyes John's
probably even heard of him so he's like
all right let's do it yeah I know yeah
like when you're not gonna get up you're
at this level and then they give you
these young lines he's like all right
you know I should be able to beat these
fun guys in my sleep it's mental he's
not like on train is hard you don't put
everything you got into it and you're
not as you're not as nervous and when
you're not as nervous that you're not
like have that little bit of fear you
have you have less adrenaline
and John just assumed he'd beat them now
I do now one if you are bent on Sarah
gone it's not a terrible bet but if you
are bet on him zero God I think he's the
first guy since Rampage and Alexander
Gusman maybe DC that actually thinks he
can beat him like God's like I don't
know what to tell you but I'm pause I'm
gonna beat the [__] ass dude and like
where's that confidence conference I
don't know it's weird but I think I'm
gonna beat the [__] out of him yeah I'm
like good for you man it ain't happening
but good for you you know I said it
ain't happening what makes you think Jon
Jones is getting up for this fight
people are leaving them out of the goat
conversation which drives them nuts like
you've never seen like you don't see
Michael Jordan LeBron do a little bit
but he's a bit of a soy boy but there's
just you'll never see a guy who's of his
stature will literally get on Twitter
like nah how are you gonna leave me out
of the goat list everyone's like what
the [__] is John coming on this and then
he came out with his own code list to
put himself number one he's like top
five to ever do it Jon Jones number one
you're like I agree who was two on his
list uh Anderson Silva khabib GSP I
forget the fifth who who's your top five
John number one Mighty Mouse khabib
the goat conversation and like pound for
pound is all there's no legit list but
to me it's like you're you're how long
you reigned as champ in the competition
your your strength of schedule like
Alabama is number one for reasons
George's number one reason because their
strength schedule they fight the they
play the best of the best every [__]
week it's doggy dog and then you have
like USC or whoever it is or TCU it's
like they're not the best man they're
not fighting or playing against the best
of the best John fought the best of the
best for 12 years he says more title
defenses than anybody anybody he has
more title defenses than Sarah God has
fight son yeah but it's nuts and he's
fighting and this is back in the day
where you could do a little juicy juicy
so he's not fighting Vitor Bell for
weather down he's fighting Vitor belfon
all the acai
and he's fighting guys that light
heavyweight where if you zigwin should a
zag you get knocked out Mighty Mouse
khabib GSP whoever else in your top five
they can make some mistakes John
couldn't make mistakes and still beat
the greatest of all time yeah what about
your list uh
Mount Rushmore though oh yeah but that's
never my goal would be the best
what was your goal make money yeah this
is a job yeah I want to be the I want to
be the most Entertainer but but how far
back can you go with a goat this because
I agree with him but I will put uh horse
Gracie on there right you know what I'm
saying to that argument and this is why
it's like yeah that's that's a valid I
put Ronda Rousey on there which you did
for women's MMA the way she dominated
for that stint of time choose the Hoist
the shoes the Hoist Gracie of women's
MMA but then the game caught up with it
doesn't take away from how good she was
don't take away how good hoist Gracie
was it's just the game evolves for
khabib
he's a rapper wrestler so his margin of
air is way wider because he's not
standing in the pocket trading like John
a trade right like Anderson Silva you
know which is different Mighty Mouse
dominant as [__] there's arguing he's
all the time probably the most talented
from top to bottom he's so talented he's
good at [__] everything
but he's fighting at what 125. yeah who
gives a [__] yeah people don't care no
no and that's no shade I'm just saying
like if he gets hit once you're like
damn won't do that again John gets hit
one it's over it's over
and people argue that Fedor was the best
of all time during his ear that run for
sure but when you talk about straight
skill like a prime Kane Velasquez is the
best heavyweight I've ever seen nobody
beats a prime Kane Velazquez yeah he was
a man his cardio his wrestling his jiu
jitsu's boxing get the [__] out of here
he's steeping on steroids but not taking
stairs you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah yeah
guess what I'm doing don't [__] with his
kids but that's what I'm doing um you
know I'm friends with Bob Sapp right I
love Bob Sapp so I'm going out to um
Thailand to train with him for a month
and then he asked me he was like man do
me a favor like what you need what you
need he said I want you to do a two
two-headed kickboxer fight with me two
headed means what you guys are like
taped together yeah it's about in the
ring together against two other guys
that'd be scary yeah you wouldn't bump
stop me and Bob against who I don't know
who the [__] the other person they gonna
get [__] up
so your left hook pops up right hand and
then you and Bob yeah Bob sap how big is
Bob right now he told me the other day
he's 310 10 pounds will doesn't know he
played in the NFL he played in NFL was
Bob Sapp in The Longest Yard yeah he's
the guy like you broke my nose
he's seven four to me he's [__] the
biggest person I've ever seen he listen
right now he's seven percent body fat
dude in Japan in Japan like China like
in Asia he's Tom Cruise yeah
and listen they're not scared of his big
dick that's how he he got Zilla he had
his own dildos in Japan dude huge he was
on cereal boxes make the print of him
huh yeah they molded they molded his
dick and they got his own dildo in Japan
listen this guy this guy else this guy
overnight become one of the most famous
people in Japan overnight I was there
witnessing like he can walk the streets
here and everyone's like that's a big
[__] dude what do you play football
he's in Japan or Tokyo you can't go
anywhere you can't go nowhere he's
[__] Tom Cruise
I pretend like I'm Bob Sapp to a little
stupid Japanese people
I mean I've been trying to get groupies
and [__]
trying to get the runoff
when I do that yeah
you broke his thing he's a monster right
crocod beat him uh uh he beat Henry hoof
Henry hoof beat him monster his whole
thing was it was here his heart if you
put rampage's heart in Bob Sapp
he's undefeated currently nobody ever
beats the [__] guy he's he's a freak
dude [__] freak he beat he beat um
and that's a who's though yes that's
what I'm saying that's the who's
you know you know what you know what
happened he got so famous
and he got to do so much stuff he
couldn't train that's what it was he
couldn't train he was so famous doing
commercials and TV shows he was on
cereal boxes out there and [__] and then
he uh you know he's doing that broke uh
big knocks back remember big dog oh
that's right like a triangle he's like
oh really say less cool dude I'm six
nine 500 pounds picked him up and
[__] just slammed on his neck and
broke his back broke his back he was
[__] well I've never been the same
yeah it's just a good idea that was good
yeah
uh yeah I trained there yeah with Gordo
who was uh used to train with big nog I
went to his Gym training again I looked
back I'm like that's a bad idea yeah
they tell them everything they told him
everything bro they stick together like
a [__] [__] I trained I
trained in Brazil uh when I was going to
fight uh Texas Aaron but then I got I
got injured and I got injured in Brazil
and normally I fight injured anyway but
Dana White had um my last fight I fought
uh what's that kid Ryan Bader I fought
him I found him injured and I lost
decision right in Japan and Dana White
threw me up on the bus like oh I don't
think Rampage is hard as into it no more
but he knew I had a tournament meniscus
oh damn I told him I said Dane I'm
injured but I'm still going to fight
because in Japan Japan I don't want to
pull it out and so this time I got
injured in in
um Brazil I got my arm kick and you know
it locked up yeah
I learned the hard way yeah
hey back when you were talking about uh
uh which which fighter you're talking
about beating back when you know so and
so can you somebody could be on some
stuff what kind of stuff could guys get
away with back then everything name is
stero for real yeah back in the day yeah
back in the day before you started
especially Pride days Pride days they
encouraged everybody it was in the
contract like please take steroids yeah
yeah yeah uh you said it's been around
for like four years five years oh only
four or five years more than I'm sure
bring that up Jen I think two times
anything 18. everyone
uh what when when you were fighting yeah
when I thought I lost the Jon Jones I
want to get my testosterone tested 2015.
what was it oh they've been around eight
years it was 200. no [__] that is low
that's super low so you probably get
personal you probably got prescribed and
then you'll see it louder they're giving
out trt exemptions and then once that
flooded if you're under what number yeah
I want to say in the NFL it's like over
300 or two I don't know I thought I
think it's in the NFL it's like 250 but
you I think you got to test like four
times now this is not this is not exact
but I think if you test like four times
a row under two but guys can't get a trt
exemption
but as you should like the UFC should do
the same thing too because they used to
yeah they used to and but then people
[__] it up Nate my card
um
bro he ran
he was at a press conference he would
say hey man am I pissing this cup he's
like yeah I'll be right there and just
ran out the door
that was like the story I don't know the
like Trail soda tells the story I wasn't
there I can't vouch for it but you know
someone talks about that you thought it
came and he was hiding underneath the
wreath see how was it yeah or heard the
story oh child has it he is on his uh
podcast yeah I heard you song they could
just pop up on you anytime anywhere
unless you're Conor McGregor and yeah
hey when I thought when I fought um
Force Griffin when I fought Force
Griffin Dana White thought I was on
steroids he said it to me personally he
said he said Rampage you don't stare all
the time because um in between fights
you gain a lot of weight you get big you
gain a lot of weight and and
um that's when I first started having
problems I thought I had problems with
my thyroid and when I this when it first
started happening and I was like uh I
don't know damn steroids I totally gets
that [__] and he he [__] he did it
himself he he texted me and I was and he
was like damn he called you out he
called me out I ain't text me like what
the he said damn man I always thought
you was on steroids because you know
people in Pride yeah
how was it when you started taking uh
trt when I first started taking him I
felt it I felt good I felt good and this
is when you lost a John you're trying to
tell you you're like man I'm trying to
fight I was trying to see what was wrong
with me because I was so that was the
first fight that I ever lost when I was
100 like you never fight 100 my injury I
was good I was on supplements for the
first time in my life because I never
even really took supplements and I and I
was training in Denver I was running
seven miles and I was [__] people I
was knocking people out and training and
stuff but what I [__] up that I didn't
have no tall guys to do Jiu Jitsu with
which right was that John Jones yeah and
and I thought I thought I was going to
beat the [__] out of John John I was so
overconfident and then when he beat me
and I was like what the [__] that I want
to go get my testosterone test it was
lady was like you've you've um abused
steroids before having you I was like no
she said she said you have to because
there's no way you would test this low
and they're off on that because if you
grew up fighting and and doing Combat
Sports and wrestling like all that
non-stop training especially football
too if like I played football since I
was six type of football that suppresses
your testosterone yeah all that stress
on your body oh I I got tested for low
testosterone in college but they
wouldn't give you exemptions yeah so I
was just like all right yeah I mean that
whole stress on your body but even
mentally too yeah like all the you know
all the [__] you got to put yourself
through mentally so I told you cat Cat
Daddy got it done via submission 17-0
now yeah he choked them out standing
choke he's 17 though 17-0 he's a Savage
dude super Savage now weight driven I'll
tell you what fella spring has sprung
and our friends at manscape have the
best tools for some spring cleaning
Rampage they've already helped you tidy
up all the nooks and crannies of your
body's basement to get a dick like uh
silky smooth
this year can help you get the perfect
presentation on that beautiful face with
the new beard hedger Pro kit make sure
you look your best this spring by using
the code shop 20 that's schab20 to get
20 off and free shipping at manscape.com
the kit starts off with the beard hedger
a waterproof cordless trimmer all right
they got all sorts of stuff to get that
beard put the Philly fade on your beard
look how you put the Hat on Rogue and I
love it when they do that that the the
translator looks like the guy from South
Park they goes okay uh cap it off with
the beard bomb a Pomade that shape
Styles and moisturizes that beautiful
beard of yours say 20% off and free
shipping with the code shop20 that's sdh
ab20 at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the coach shop20 at
manscape.com focus on the face and use
the beard hedger Pro kit for the
cleanest look in the game
but his is like uh is this like a
raccoon is that like a fox Joe Rogan
don't look right hey he really doesn't
with that hat you're gonna look good
yeah nothing looks right right now on TV
it was a tubuku okay the two books like
uh in Vietnamese they call it too big
yeah but they call it but how they
really say is Keck bug
my friends Vietnamese I heard him
laughing I said oh really yeah
it's black right when I would try to
talk when I used to try to talk
now I mean I'm like no okay
[Laughter]
and for Koreans they say uh
you know what they call black people in
Japanese
do you know what they call Korean
I don't date Asians anymore no you
learned your lesson I learned my [__]
lessons how did you learn your lesson
they stopped liking me
or you just frequent the same Vietnamese
boy no no I I honestly I don't like
Vietnamese girls like that I'm just
there has to be a dating app we can get
y'all for just aging like 80.com Aces no
more man come on no no no
my first when I first moved it when I
first moved here
I saw that I saw the Vietnamese girls
and I'm like damn these girls are hot as
[__] but then they stuck up and they
like black chicks they're like they're
too much like black chicks which means
most of them don't date outside their
race they're [__] like very very like
aggressive opinionated and bossy yeah
[__] that yeah I'm an alpha man I need a
submissive chick so what'd you get a
white girl white girls that's a missile
yeah I like Purge I like Persian
Persians persian's new thing Dave you
just cultured man I like culture yeah I
like variety yeah
see new things Persians right now watch
your mouth got a G wagon and [__] watch
your mouth what's your mouth crazy you
know they remind me of uh when um what's
that what's that that was that rapper
what's that rapper name um he was on
that morning talk show and it was like
you're gonna is she gonna be your new
girl I hope so
on the radio show
so the rapper with the crazy with the
craziest
Club how about uh Jake Gyllenhaal what a
smoke show am I right I don't know what
you're talking about he oh so yeah you
can't say he's a good looking cat no but
bring it up chin they did a fake
weigh-in because you don't think Jake
Joe you can't you can't save another
man's a good looking cat or not I could
say if I'm related to him well he hasn't
seen his body though but he did a fake
way he's ripped yeah he is Jack oh boy
he got six-pack like a ninja turtle but
you got you caught another man a smoke
shop yeah absolutely
it's not a sweet like that yeah I'm not
sweet like that but like you know I can
you know you'll give it easy yeah
you make a mistake get drunk and you run
over somebody you kill them you got you
got hang on 20 years ago yeah 20 years
in prison kill somebody run them over
kill somebody
he's 20 years in prison not your fault
you just [__] up yeah yeah
he's your cell mate
yeah absolutely I consider it
[Laughter]
20 years we're talking 20 years Rampage
man you can't go 20 years without
without you know
years Rampage hey
[__] it what happens if your prison uh
sells like an Asian boy
and he's folding your laundry so he had
two hands rubbing your back I got two
hands though yeah yeah two hands and
grab that little Asian dude
you couldn't go 20 years no
he's just like [__] it uh I don't know
man I have to be in there but come on
bro so I'm saying like we'd have to be
in there we're talking about 20 years
you ever gave up sex for Lent you
haven't done the whole length no I'm not
religious like that you literally said
earlier that you were like uh I'm a
Child of God I'm not religious God God
really is no religion religion's
man-made okay okay so I I used to be
religious yeah I will but yeah he took
me to school real quick yeah
but but uh but you know I've I've went
time I went like nine months I was
married and my wife had a kid at the
time so I went six what six weeks
we all know that we all know that
boundary yeah yeah yeah yeah like hey
sweetheart like yeah I've been nine
months in my life and six six weeks I
think this as long as I've been without
it
good for you what sucks in those six
weeks too it's like why you gotta shut
down the entire park just because one
roller coaster
I can't go through the back doors
yeah what's up that's right I forgot
about that yeah she didn't give me no
top or nothing nothing selfish I need to
call that [__] up and tell her
oh yeah yeah yeah man I'll tell you the
only this is a great companion it'd be
better if jelly roll is here what
happens
he got stuck at the airport at first you
know when your buddy's like oh man I
ain't gonna make him like oh here we
folded last minute he sent me a video of
him from the airport being like I swear
I'm here right now TSA ain't letting me
in man I don't know what the [__] dude
I'm not gonna make it they're bringing
this rain made me think of jelly because
he'll down seven of these bro and still
fall asleep it made me feel bad how bad
it was when I was late though and
Generals
of Beast oh you gotta you should have
saw his reaction yeah I kept I kept him
I kept them in a loop on Instagram
you're fine brother and I came here you
got a lot of [__] going on because when
do you go to uh hang out with Bob Sapp
and get tied together
I leave uh Tuesday oh yeah how long a
month I'm trying to get ripped like him
buying If he if he owns some [__] I
ain't doing none of that [__] hey look
at me
because it might not be healthy like it
might have sound effects that's why I
never really side effects like getting
jacked bro you wanna be Jake general or
not man have you ever seen those people
that's real fit and they have like
yellow eyeballs and yeah they're doing
too much [__] yes yeah when your eyes
gain muscles you have too much [__] you
could easily get hooked up with a doctor
though and do that hormone replacement
therapy [__] like get your blood taken
no we're trying to get on some real [__]
here well you're trying to as well yeah
that's what I'm saying I feel like you
got to get your blood taken and stuff
like yeah get that stuff measured I just
want to get back in shape bro I found it
I got a trainer now my one of my good
friends he's like a fitness model it's
hard to train right when you go from
fighting yeah it's like you just don't
give a [__] don't give a bar because you
don't have a goal yeah yeah but my goal
is the kitchen he's right because well I
we like I feel like probably all of us
we can go into the weight room and still
like you know [__] around sweat I can
throw some things yeah throw some things
like what the linebackers do when it
gets past six or seven o'clock and you
just start getting hungry like I know I
got somebody and you know you're you're
not like training for a fight or
training for you for football or nothing
and you got some snacks in the pantry
like you just can't that sweet tooth
comes knocking and what's funny is like
I know how y'all do it both my girl for
whatever reason it's like if people see
you eat it counts more so like I'll go
in the pantry and down like you know
we're getting Oreos I might throw in
four oh they're double star I might do
it fast yeah I might throw in like four
Oreos before I walk out with three
inches but I mean just oh I gotta cut I
got like those four Oreos didn't just
counting the pants yeah you know bro I
got busted too because we have ice cream
I took my back to the kids and my girl I
was like this she's like what the [__]
are you doing I'm like what she's like
are you eating ice cream I'm like yeah
she's like why do you hide it what's
wrong with me I don't know it's almost
like if you don't see it I feel like I'm
doing something bad yeah
but yeah uh yeah if Bob's got some good
stuff that's the thing like I would want
to do the blood work and stuff to know
really I think so but yeah just full of
sand bro shooting my veins
he didn't tell me he was on [__] he told
me I don't need him to tell me
normal dosage trt I didn't use like
death or nothing like that is it true
that if you start trt then you're you
stop producing that natural testosterone
yeah your nuts get smaller than your
body because your nuts go oh he already
has it we can just shut down but it just
stops permanently no you can take stuff
like uh clothing stuff to fire the nuts
back up and then they get big again dude
you got to get yourself like weekly nut
massages you can yeah or you can hired
an Asian
or Persian whatever I want to make it
because I don't only like I don't have
an Asian fetish
that's the thing about me in Orange
County though that I have an Asian
fetish well I think I think yeah because
there's no Asians in Orange County
that's all it is I think you you did a
good job of that yourself no work
because I speak a few words in certain
few agents you speak more fluent than
chin bro you literally go Asian cougar
and you stood that blood started to fly
no no no I just said
Asian cougars are the best looking
cougars and then he spoke to Korean in
us
like oh my God I'm just I just met you
brother I spoke a little Japanese right
here but Paige I know girls I know you
I've run that Circle in Orange County
yeah so yeah
but they figure awesome yeah and I don't
be hitting on them do it not all of them
yeah
not all of them it's public knowledge
that you're about it I saw the video who
was it Nate Diaz oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah look it's like I said it's
like rumors there's no shame in that I
don't know why is this a bad thing no
I'm gonna tell you this Godzilla of
Orange County I married a Japanese woman
so you're horny you like puss bro it's
all good I'm a man I like puss I married
a Japanese woman and I've dated a few
Asian girls and so people assume that
that's your type yeah that's fine if it
is
they hear you say Asian cougars are the
best I'm just keep it real hey my
opinion Asian cougars are the best yeah
it's because they don't age that's right
but as soon as the midnight hits when
they turn 70 they turn to smeagle but
you ain't funny you done [__] them by
the time they 70.
I'm not [__] somebody 70. it depends
how you look I'm Gonna Be Rich As [__]
S7 I'm gonna [__] a 30 year old chick at
70. yeah but how are you gonna look you
know I'm gonna look like a Nutty
Professor guess what when you got money
women don't give a [__] how you look
these are facts Rampage you're dropping
facts yeah you got money you see some
ugly dudes
[__] yeah they got money and you're
like what oh I know what's going on
there yeah like I probably has a small
dick yeah I'm gonna be though I'm be
throwing old dick and all these young
[__] when I get old
and be like Grandpa dad Grandpa dead
I'll be having a bunch of babies I die
shooting dust out that yeah are you the
uh horniest guy you know no no actually
I'm not that horny
what are you talking about bro I'm
really not I only need sex like three
days three days a week I'm good I'm good
and how old are you I'm 44. yeah only
three days a week I'm good if I get
three three times a week you need to be
once oh okay I thought Are you seriously
I'm good man I'm so busy I'm tired
what's wrong with you yeah I'm lazy too
man I just lay there and you lay there
and she just do all the work yeah just
be doing it
uh what about you will probably a couple
times a week two to three two to three
is ideal but it doesn't happen it's all
good baby we got [__] to do you're like
I am sitting here thinking like you're
saying that in those night those days
most days when you just hit the bed at
like 10 o'clock you ready to like I'm in
bed ready to catch up and [__] yeah yeah
see I don't I don't do a whole lot of
stuff like that yeah I don't be doing a
whole lot of stuff but it's not like
what like what y'all be doing like a
whole lot of work but but I feel what he
said he's tired because I'm I'm actually
working on um doing my own uh late night
show oh that'd be dope yeah you'd crush
it yeah so I'm gonna start doing that
when I get back from Thailand so I'm
wondering if I'm start doing that I want
to start doing stuff for myself all
Asian girls like what the [__] is going
on here no
you can only book Ali Wong so many times
I want to book Lucy Ludo I used to have
a big Crystal she's dope my ex-wife used
to look like her really yeah when she
was younger
but the first girl I ever kissed was
Asian so that's why dude so it's like
this is in Memphis it's the Exotic look
you like the Exotic look because I'm the
same way
like Islanders like supposed to have
their hair wet my heart just melt like
oh I love it and they got green hair I
like exotic looking women yeah yeah yeah
no matter what race they are I agree
without it you know yeah I'm with you
yeah straight up yeah
you dropped that post
was Asian but the main reason why I I
really like Mulan was your first Disney
no [__] man [__] you trying to you're
trying to you're trying to troll me but
Asian girls you can see the [__] from
the back when they bend over
that's the reason that sexiest [__] to
me you got big black girls you gotta
like practice it apart are you like flat
asses no I didn't say that I like sexy
asses
I feel like all Races can't do that you
know you wouldn't I feel like you're
making excuses right what an honor to be
drinking with a rampage yeah he's the
best you know what most Asian girls be
smart flat ass right well you can see
that you can see the [__] there's no
deadlift in Japan yeah no
that was that was what I'm talking about
that's that's what that's what got me
going no these are facts yeah yeah you
want to see what you [__] with now
you got Alexa grass so uh fighting
chefchenko right now she's a big
underdog if she wins she's from
Guadalajara so my girl's definitely
rooting for her uh she's from galahar if
she wins the Mexico have two Champions
bran Moreno and her which when you think
of MMA don't think of Mexico she has her
hands full though against chefchenko now
a lot of people think chefchenko lost
her last fight
um but she is one of the greatest of all
time I'm gonna be rooting for the
Mexican girl just so I don't have to see
that other girl do that [__] stupid
ass day that dance yeah she's a [__]
sniper though yeah but I just I'm sick I
don't wanna that dance annoys me too and
she's all yeah I'm like God damn [__]
that dude it reminds me of the dance
that that french guy does from Street
Fighter who has the mask on he's the
ponytail that's not he's not French he's
from Spain oh that's right he's Spain
does that weird dance oh yeah her dance
is very similar she's a [__] sniper
though she's she's good she wants to
fight Amanda Nunes
why
she fought her before went to Split
Decision
Amanda she's kind of cleaned out this
division thing Alexa grass was ranked
number six fighting for a world title
you know is a man is he Champion again
yeah
and then she beat uh Penny up she beat
the [__] out of her so she lost opinion
at first right yeah beat the [__] out of
her first yeah
and then she beat the [__] opinion damn
look at Grasso ready to go and I'm room
for Grasso but I don't think she's gonna
win
good hands good Jujitsu but the kicks of
chefchenko oh [__] I didn't know the
other girl was on with monster so I have
to root for a month so we stick together
well monster sponsors all the Champs I
think yeah there's uh Mark Wahlberg
looking so serious and very uh age there
is this fight in Vegas yeah
so UFC is doing a movie now uh well
Roadhouse you know like the redoing
Roadhouse Jake johal and Conor McGregor
yeah they're supposed to be Ronda Rousey
but they switched it to Conor McGregor
Conor McGregor wow so yeah Connor's in
Roadhouse I'm interested to see how
Connor acts me too I think I saw him in
like a commercial or something yeah
Steve Jobs for the new Apple properties
he's all right bit of a hater no no no I
love him like Rampage white girls you're
hating right now no no no no no no I'm
just saying like seeing Connor acting as
commercials he's okay
some guys transition well but sometimes
they don't check the box like so
sometimes you're watching like Jesus
Christ yeah
like I don't know if you saw my acting
in tax collector
yeah you wouldn't know because they made
me wear a mask and I kept taking the
mask off they go cut Hey Big Man
because I was a cartel member shooting I
had like I was like shooting but they
had a mask on I looked all scary I kept
taking the mask off so people would
notice my face cut put them [__]
masks on am I doing good yeah yeah just
keep shooting the gun scene's not about
you I know it's throwing some extra
lines
bro if I if I do a movie I'm gonna try
to get you in there I'll be done that'd
be fun what kind of move you want to do
it you did a movie I do movies you did a
big movie 18. yo that's right bro yeah I
do movies
as [__] I saw that [__] in theaters yeah
come on bro what's up Mr T was in that
right no yeah you know what I'm saying
you played Mr yeah I played barakas but
he was also uh he made an appearance
right no he didn't he was the only one
that that was alive that didn't why
didn't you want to do it because he was
mad because he wanted to roll he was
like if y'all don't give me a roll
they're like [__] you are 80. yeah I
still got a dog
this is sad gravity is taking it over
here he said if you don't give me the
wrong one [__] to do it they said say
less well Club Rambo how about Brad
Cooper
huh
my boy got some sugar this time
okay I don't judge he's got nice eyes
right I didn't notice really hey how did
you not I know yeah you're lying Rampage
that's why I think you did a little
sweetness
lying about some of these figures
because I'm not attracted to men
yeah a question that would go around
every locker room when I was in the
league it was
how much money would it take for you to
suck a dick okay that's the easy that's
an easy [__] well you had a million
no no I'm just stupid right that's
stupid no more than that no no because
it's an easy answer for me what do you
think I don't love money
okay you know what the roots of all evil
is money no
dick no the love of the Love of Money
Dave Ramsey yeah yeah I don't love mine
yes that question don't work hey hey
Will that question is
[__] this is the first argument myself
in the mirror if I ever suck somebody I
couldn't look at myself in a mirror as
soon as you got kids
imagine let's say they give you 100 Mil
right and then your kid turns 18 he's
like yeah this house is sick you ate
this off stand up yo no no no no no no
listen sit down yeah all right we gotta
pivots for that okay would you rather
suck a dick or take it in the ass
I'll take it in the ass bro yeah and
what kind of questions are these though
maybe this is why I swear to God these
are the questions you've always got too
much times these are the questions that
gay the gay people be asking straight
people this no this is when football
players are bored in the locker room
training camp
and then your boys in Tights yeah I
heard about y'all football players I
don't think it's dicey yeah like you're
in the middle of training camps of mine
who kept a box of condoms in his locker
and uh one of the boys asked him why he
said you never know when somebody's
gonna catch a full body cramp
[Laughter]
my boy Preston Smith he's a defensive
end for the Packers he's a stud signed I
think he signed a couple deals now after
he left Washington on his rookie deal
but I was going to run the locker room
basically asking that question and guys
who you know like yourself talk about I
don't love money and just start saying
the most and they just move on all right
bro yeah you're not gonna play my game
I'm out of here they just won't have fun
with a question it was like all right
gun to your head the only way to get out
of it is if you suck a dick would you do
it are you gonna die or you die get out
of what you get shot gun to the Head
cartel comes up gun the head like you
better suck this dick I'm dead
here's where I made the next pivot you
had do you have uh you have kids yeah I
got kids gun to their head that's
different you got it yeah
so if you love your kids you gay
hey look but Preston he was talking
about he was talking about his daughter
and I was like well I think I said his
mom he calls his mom on speaker yeah his
mom goes you better let me die you
better not suck no dick he's like see
cop what did I tell you everybody's
hanging up laughing it was hilarious but
so you would I love my kids man can you
tell he's asked this question a thousand
times whatever answer you have we're
gonna get that answer yeah
listen hey everybody it's always the day
before the game you know when you're
doing the walk through yeah
I'm literally walking up and down just
asking them hey bro
hey come here real quick his question is
like how many of you guys gay like me
and then some guy's like you don't want
to be by myself dude NFL Network you got
to be mic'd up
if you love your kids you're gay
I feel like grosso's doing a pretty damn
good job ooh take got to Great take down
my chefchenko
I ain't gonna lie I almost asked which
kid you talking about
that also had a good ride
[Applause]
what are you talking about he's trying
to get out of that man he's ready to go
yeah
yeah let's get this game going right now
I saw something on social media that uh
like that is uh these guys with face
masks had to put I'm sure you guys saw
put a gun is on the hand and totally uh
you know they put a gun to her head and
and said I'm gonna kill everybody unless
you shoot one of your kids
and I haven't seen that before it was it
was nice it's a joke
what are they trying to get people to
answer it yeah yeah so it's like oh it's
like a tick tock prank it was like it
was like it was it was just during that
dark parade no it was a video it was a
video like it was like a joke thing oh
yeah
and they had the husband sitting there
and the boys and then they were like you
better do it now you got five seconds
I'm gonna kill all y'all so either you
killed one of your boys or everybody
Gotta Die so so she shot one of her boys
and and then the boy turned
you you kill me then the guys they took
the mask off they said I told the boys
not to see now you now you know which
one of your one your mom loves to leave
with the information you want yeah yeah
it was funny that's funny yeah because
you were thinking of the uh you were
thinking no no you would yeah you were
thinking the one you'd let go yeah yeah
yeah yeah they're like I think I was
thinking like if I you know if you if
you were in that situation I'm like yeah
which kid
you know I'm shooting myself yeah yeah
you shoot yourself
for the for the fun of the game yeah you
know he'll tell you too serious
dicks bro be cool man because I don't
think because I don't think we didn't
even have to get to the point where he
said he'd kill one of his kids I don't
think about sucking dude's dicks no but
you do now right tonight yeah tonight
hey y'all ain't turning me again
he said you would do it no no well you
entertained it for a couple years ago I
don't give a [__] y'all not turning me I
like your answer though no no amount of
money what about for you will yeah you
know the amount of money amount of money
there was a so there was a daughter
there yeah yeah there's a tick tock
going on saying would you suck a dick
for 100 million dollars and
100 million cash in the bank I'm remade
the video I played the clip would you
suck a dick for 100 million dollars and
then it shot to me and I was in the
bathroom getting on my knees 100 Mil and
would you fetch out there you can follow
me underscore what you want to do with
the 100 million dollars sit on it I'm
gonna sleep on it wash my mouth but but
here's the thing though there's there's
also stipulations like it could be
private No One Ever Knows No you know if
No One Ever Knows Your Mouth knows yeah
your mouth no you know
though
I would probably invest link up with
people and grow an Empire
pretty smart yeah you turn 100 get
wealthier yeah yeah
all from sucking dick
you have no one new either if no one
knew if no one knew famous they're gonna
tell somebody
no one knows the guy he's got it okay
put it like this I found it glory hole I
found it yeah hey here's a here's you
know whose dates coming through well
yeah Rampage or let's say this after you
suck after you suck the dude's dick you
get to kill him it's kind of like an
aunt or I'm a murderer yeah that's a lot
to take on dude I think I'm sucking dick
and murder I think the same face a
million in therapy bills
now you're a homosexual murderer
yeah you
just because you do one thing doesn't
mean that that's what you are
it's like I try black licorice I know I
hate black licorice like that [__] is
terrible no way I love it I'm British
man hey what the [__] does that mean
they love black licorice but you know
you know what I'm saying if you don't
like you gotta take food to know you
don't like it they might hey if you cut
one hair one dude's head one time all
right you know you're not a barber
one day
nah bro your dick sucker sucker no you
don't want street fight you're not a
fighter right and sometimes you got to
know you gotta suck a dick to know you
don't like sucking dicks yeah don't
knock it till you try it that's what
we'll say now this sounds like Will's
trying to get us to suck his dick
I was dating this this girl and she had
a gay best friend and and we would go
places together and like the ambient
chip oh you in the gay best friend would
go places yeah all three of us it's not
like you said YouTube
she got she had a gay best friend and
and we'll be going out going to eat or
going to club or whatever and she always
brought him along and we'd be walking
after you talking and he would just come
around and get on my he was a little
bitty dude yeah
hey bro you get too comfortable man yeah
I'm like bro just disrespect he would
say some [__] up [__] I was like bro
disrespect me yeah that I'm straight to
town and was he cool I told him I said
listen bro you want me to respect you
he's like yeah I was like respect me
down straight yeah he got it he got it
he had some balls on him no pun intended
because for him to keep [__] with
yeah
I mean he would say he would say like
some [__] up [__] he's trying to [__]
dude I don't give a [__] yeah
what if he was Asian he was he was I was
gonna tell you for sure yeah he was
Asian but he's a good he's life of the
party right
he was funny
I think I think I think um a lot of gay
people be super happy yeah y'all some
happy people bro
you know that's what Gabe meant back in
the day yes too yeah yeah you remember
that's true remember
um the first time when you have the Gale
Gale time yeah hell yeah I bet you had a
bunch of gay old times every now and
then every now and then have a gay old
time hey does uh does Mike Grable you
guys are still boys yeah
he texted me the other day because he's
at the combine he goes I found your
replacement he took himself with this
linebacker I found your replacement just
some random dude yeah just some random
guy that's your boy is Taylor uh does he
know is he gonna retire or if he gets a
fat ass offer I think he's still trying
to play I think he's still trying to
play he's just so he had the first
surgery right a couple years ago knee
surgery towards ACL two years ago last
year I don't know if you remember like I
don't know how much I don't know how
much you keep up with all this stuff
like in the NFL but the first week
he had a rough go with against like
Chandler Jones against Arizona Cardinals
challenge Jones pretty good very yeah
very good but Jon Jones bro yeah but he
had like an up and down year which is
unheard of for him because he's former
All-Pro like yeah
three Pro bowls in a row one of the
highest paid tackles of all time set the
record when he yeah when he got paid it
would use the highest of all time
yeah but that year he got popped oh nice
job oh you got popped for PDS Dustin uh
something got Dustin with Austrian he
had a very low amount of Austrian in his
system from uh from some supplement from
a guy we believe that right uh yeah I do
yeah I do believe that from some guy he
was working with that like you know it's
not like it's not like Taylor was so
around like knowledge wise around it so
he was putting his trust in for sure
somebody else dude yeah and it was a
supplemented style and again it was a
product that was Dustin and and you know
being in the you saw the game you have
to find like you have to go so detailed
on the lot number of the supplement from
where it was created in the exactly like
you gotta figure out which which land
very low amount of of Austrian that
tested uh when he tested positive and so
that next year after his three Pro bowls
in a row and then when he signed the big
deal he came back from that four game
suspension that's the year they went to
the AFC Championship like they were
rolling balling yeah he was balling he
played at a high level that year well
the next year
he uh he tore his ACL the year after is
when I was talking about the up and down
year this past year he tore his ACL
again but but when he went in and got it
was getting it looked at it seemed like
they might have they potentially could
have messed up his first ACL oh wow so
he's going through a lot of stuff too so
then is there a legal action there I
don't know I don't know like I
personally don't don't know like all the
steps that he's taken like obviously
poor guy must be yeah oh very I mean
second game of the year first play of
the game got sniped you know ACL went
out again who were they playing uh the
Buffalo Bills it was a Thursday night
games going against Von Miller he's
pretty good yeah awesome but it would
have been a nice like get back game like
you know coming back against the boys
um but so he battled that and then had
to go and get all the second opinions
and stuff like that so he's kind of even
he's kind of in that game so is he kind
of over it you know what I'm saying like
after going through all this [__]
you know
he said he wants to play yeah yeah like
at the end of the day he wants to play
like he wants his knee to be right he
wants to be a Hall of Famer yeah he he
probably is at this point
bro Hall of Fame bro Hall of Fame you
got to put especially as an alignment
you got to put a lot of consistent years
Davis got him for playing for four years
TD TD we played six years but four years
was when he was balling but we're
talking about a running back true you
know what I mean like oh lineman you got
five on the other line guys are playing
double digit years that's true you know
yeah that's true putting all that stuff
together Taylor got three Pro bowls uh I
think he might have been like a second
team All-Pro one year but no all Pros
like that
um but he got cut from the Titans that
ultimately you know if I'm speaking for
in my perspective and I had his career
I'm like damn you hate to go out [__]
like that with the last three years we
put together you kind of want to get
back yeah I get it
um so I know he just wants to get his
knee right yeah he wants to get his knee
right now yeah I saw you post someone
photoshopped him in a Raiders uniform he
looked dope yeah bro cause we've we've
been messing around like we're packaging
and me I'm trying to ride that coattail
like yeah
we're free agents for the first time in
our careers were we going to be fair
like left tackles are hard to find yeah
you're not gonna find that Taylor
Launches on the [__] Street you don't
play on the perimeter and also get a
little one in this no no no no no no no
oh yeah yeah yeah you're right he is
he's a [__] free yes yeah who you can
put on an island and be like hey you're
you're dealing with this you're dealing
with this
nasty yes finished plays yes absolutely
run block passes can do it all yeah can
play on the second and third level freak
damn it's a legit fight who do you have
winning chin I'm gonna talk about dicks
with Will and Rampage
I didn't pay attention enough but uh
[__] come on man I saw someone had it
1-1 in this last round what do you think
price Chef Chang got sold the takedowns
33. what do you think Jay how old are
you so Jay thinks when I was getting
hyped for you on the a team and
everything else like your prime years
was my high school like this was you get
together you get together on Saturdays
and watch the fights legit my only
Affliction shirt Rampage Jackson that's
what's up this is
it's a big deal it's a big deal it's a
big deal now Rampage inflation shirt was
dope that was back when you walk in
buckling you walk straight oh being
young you walk straight for the
Affliction church but now I bet he cut
that that refrigerator up to like a crop
top
it's a cut off jean shorts
don't get one of them chains from one of
them uh kiosks in the middle of the mall
yeah thinking you're tight like a cross
necklace like yeah damn there it is
right there no that's not the one though
no that's not the dope one that's the
one right there with the wolves with the
wolves that was the number one yeah no
that one right there on the right that
one right there is the one I had this
one right here no no go to the where
your fingers on left to the left that
one yeah that was the number one that
was the number one selling one right
there yeah
do they own the design [__] them
yeah I'm with you but with business and
legal no I can just drive you put two
wolves in Chains and just oh they have
three wefts let's do one wolf
yeah you could redo it they don't own
the wolf design we'll do a new one you
do three different ones with chains they
don't own the wolf design right I'm
gonna make one special for for where I'm
gonna put a gay wolf on there
yeah I'm telling you right now I'm um
yeah I'm gonna make it again it'd be
different wolves
I don't like those wolves anyway
nah those ones are too skinny can't get
thicker ones yeah get thick wood yeah
they'll be sick
they got two of us we put three dude I'm
not gonna put a scream Couture you know
you know that's why I don't [__] with
Randy Couture in the morning deal no no
he wasn't oh you saw him at the hall of
fame because of you I talked to him
because what you told was your advice I
talked to him but I didn't I didn't I
didn't I didn't like I didn't I didn't
like tell him
like uh I didn't tell him but I actually
talked to him and then yeah it's it's
squash you could do yeah and you don't
want to hold that resentment yeah yeah
because because of you I talked to him
good because both Legends there's no
need for that you guys yeah yeah he had
that extreme Couture line yeah that was
yeah I was sponsored by him that was
scream Couture Fletcher just went under
the
just fell under right like they started
to fight league and then yeah they still
sell Affliction they still sell it but
it's not it used to be every everywhere
bro they were and didn't the owner die
I think died I might be making that up
no something happened I mean back when I
had it it was like what 07 2007. I'm
telling you that's everywhere every oh
who's the biggest shirt I think they
said I think they're still big they
still sell overseas and stuff I Know I
Know Rich Franklin had an issue with
them
that was when me personally I was most
into the UFC obviously you guys been in
and following it the entire time they
[__] up that's when I was like
literally yeah
we would all get in the house they got
too big for the britches
yeah UFC kicked them out yeah you never
got into the like the Conor McGregor
when he's coming up yeah yeah but I'm
but I'm saying like
when Conor was coming up I was in
college right because one was kind of
coming up what years
he would have started and were about
2016. oh wait no no I would have been in
Washington yeah yeah I would have been
in Washington when he was coming up I
remember I remember when Connor was on
like Jim Rome is burning saying like I'm
the next big thing in the UFC
yeah there you go Affliction uh
co-founder Todd beard oh I'm thinking
about oh it's our beard he did pass away
Tom beard did I remember talking but he
was a good guy how did he pass away
let's see was this a steamroller
it just says passed away too soon
he just told that story as afraid that
was the first time he told that story
and his brother got shot in the head
but he's still alive oh damn look
she choked her out she tapped what wow
I'm so glad I did not bet on that
baby we got a champ do not cry that's
amazing No Cry Cry you're not about to
cry you're not about a good cry you beat
Chef that's because you think you also
think entertainment
I think that's why legit somebody who
cries I feel like they're not even
thinking about entertainment dude all
they're thinking about is Mexico has two
children four walls they lived in the
entire training camp Oh that's [__]
vert beat Chef tanko that's insane and
now it was coming because Chef changer
did not look right in her last fight a
lot of people thought she lost that
fight so this one
you ever cried Rampage she [__] up so
many parlors I can't remember last time
I cried
you ever been in therapy no uh anger
management
is that therapy nah I have no clue
unless I don't think so I had to quit
because it was making me angry yeah
that's awesome it wasn't helping it
wasn't happening at all why you went for
what reason well when I got when I got
trouble in college yeah I got in trouble
College even back then they were so
young like it's not gonna do that yeah
yeah they yeah like
very Wideman style here
and then got her neck I heard Jitsu is
filthy good for her man
Mexicans are celebrating from horchata
filthy that's why I am glad I did not
send that bet slip in yeah that [__]
up so many parlays I was building out a
parlay the only one I was going to keep
out was the Jon Jones fight but I had a
parlay going but damn fortunately the
show started
damn oh the spinning back kick across
the same
it causes it for her man the division
needs some fresh air like it's good
she's chair like Chef Chang has been
raining champ for a while nobody's even
close to beating her except for that
last girl but other than that I'm sure
she got rematch claws though
yeah that's why you're a rematch oh and
what I wanted to ask about when you were
talking about Ronda Rousey being the
goat
um is that even close
women's coat not even close yeah people
say a man who knows but there's no
Amanda Nunez without Rhonda just like
there's no Rampage about who is Gracie
I agree with you but did Rhonda did she
ever lose and come back and get it no no
that's what I'm saying I feel like that
has to matter but again
does Dana admirally said women will
never fight in the UFC then Veronica
came along he's like hold up she's a
monster right so then she paved the way
just like always Gracie did now of
course Gracie fought Rampage to get his
[__] head knocked off but there's no
Rampage about who he's crazy you're
right but if you're talking about
there's no there's there's absolutely no
MMA without Hicks and Grace if you want
to go even back that far right Dixon was
the real [__]
it's like you can go before UFC one and
be like there's no UFC one without
somebody who was for sure probably in
the Gracie Camp yeah hoist was the one
that came to America Hixson went to Asia
got you
man I remember my old man would
literally [__] we were in our we were
in our double wide and Park Hills and he
would put in the VHS grew up in a
trailer park double wide yeah [__] yeah
dude not grew up probably until about
probably until about eight years old
kind of grew up eight maybe eight years
in the trailer park yeah about eight
years old I want to say shape your third
or fourth grade is when we got to to
volunteer the small the small town so
parents were struggling too I mean I
guess a little bit you're gonna [__]
for sure for sure but you're you know
you know how it is like you're not
thinking like you have a bad life no my
parents were awesome no you knew as long
as you had a good family you're right
right for sure but I remember my old man
he would literally put in the [__]
VHS of UFC one and make me watch that
[__] all the time the uh the dude with
one glove yeah and the dude the dude who
took the shin to the fat guy yeah bro
literally remember that just open hand
the Sumo dude yeah yeah that's Sumo dude
I met the dude with the one glove at the
Bellator that same night oh he did yeah
he was there he's cool as [__] wait
which guy the dude that [__] with the
one boxing glove he get mad at me
because he said I made fun of him in the
interview or a podcast one down sure
yeah one Club throwing some boots but he
was actually pretty cool
do you have one club on so people
recognize them
[Laughter]
hey I want to learn more about this this
um double wide okay I heard about the
trailer it'd be a lot of uh like girls
there where you can smash smash like
live like a couple houses in the trailer
park brother we're talking I'm talking
seven eight years old so he wasn't
smashing at seven eight years old no I
was no you weren't what eight years old
Rampage that's why they call you Rampage
yeah no doubt bro when did you lose
everything young when did you lose your
virginity except four months old
I don't even know what you were doing I
didn't know what I was doing we was just
dry humping and I guess she had been
molested or something because she like
you ain't doing nothing she pulled her
pants to the side and put my little dick
in there damn five he was able to get a
little yeah you know Rampage though yeah
you can get hard babies can get hard I
can't remember my son when he's a baby
like yeah you did a breeze catch a boner
yeah I can't I just can't remember can
you remember how early yeah
I mean clearly
he's [__] at five dollars I'm
American Pie over here normal chocolate
when you lose your representative 16
like a normal [__] 14 was me 14 Jesus
yeah five I'd be like 14's early and I'm
here bro that's weird five both of you
combined 10 years old yeah but you
shouldn't get pregnant at five no you
can't you can't you can blow away keep
the feeling but nothing spits out oh
interesting you get the feeling like
that's the fact that you remember I
remember I remember my first time trying
to kiss all we did was like open our
mouths and like just spear each other's
open mouths CPR yeah oh [__] I was a pro
by the time I was 11. how could you not
you're [__] five okay say you [__]
at five did you continue like six seven
eight nine ten like or were there songs
Rampage here's the question you know
what I'm saying
maybe you [__] the well here's the
question was that other five-year-old
Asian
I was two
[Music]
she called me she lost me in the grocery
store and she found me a couple hours
down she got you swapping Spit with her
angel girl she said her mama thought it
was cute by the mangoes in the in the
colonial he threw on some curve there
was a curve and went damn two and five
yeah so so after five I was just dry
humping like my sister friends and I
live you know we did in the project like
a little project time out time out this
is and I apologize for interrupting but
one training camp we're all sitting
around and somebody from Mississippi and
also Memphis talked about this game
called hide and go get it oh yeah that's
a real game where have I heard about
this I didn't go B yeah Bobby green
that's right Bobby green was talking
about hide and go get it they talk about
it's basically hide and go seek but when
you find them you get to do whatever you
want sexually to him yeah now now this
way it's the most insane
I think all 50 states and now as a kid I
played hide and seek
the girl's willing
they go to a hiding spot so you can do
it so you can find them so you can yo I
had a d lime and he goes I find the
girls and they'd be like oh no anybody
come on you're like you play the game
that's a real game I didn't grow up like
that yeah how do you go get it yeah
so that's basically what you did from
five until well when I turned 11
um my best friend had like a little
sister and a cousin
that I used to smash all the time but at
the same time
well you don't take turns and you're
free what age is this I was 11. what are
you doing from six to eleven
just humping and stuff no try humping
and your mom and just whatever she
didn't know that yeah I I I grew up I
hung around older people she didn't know
yeah I was a street Punk yeah but I you
know my mom had a like at that time she
had four kids and I was right dead in
the middle she didn't give a [__] she
was busy man
uh well
well when my when I turned 10 I think my
parents got divorced but so but are you
close with your dad yeah my dad's yeah
man now where's Dad when you're five
getting your dick wet though man my dad
was proud my dad used to watch Cinemax
with us my dad my dad had me when he was
21 right so I had a cool day I remember
the first time I did finally bust I came
home and I ran home I was scared what
age were you I was about 11 and I told I
told my dad said hey I said exploded in
my pants I said my dick got a cold
he said what you mean I take out a runny
nose yeah I got snot coming out of my
dick he said what you been doing
he was like boy that ain't not going
there go in there and wash up wash up
what do you want me to do [__] put
soap in this thing you got everywhere I
thought my dick had a cold oh word I
thought you were talking about nothing
when you turn 11 then I know at 11 you
can you can shoot yeah you sure it comes
out now man the life you've lived hey
remember I started everything that's why
that's why I'm mellow now I started
drinking oh that's why you're mellow
when you were eight sorry
yeah Jesus Christ she was the coolest
eight-year-old in the world in the world
telling these other eight-year-olds like
he has he's smoking just like yeah he's
man these [__] be crazy I was [__]
at five dude I was hanging out with
grown-ups they taught me how to sell
drugs he told me I hold it I had the gun
did all this [__] man I grew up in the
hood in Memphis man what a life yeah it
was fun who has more [__] hookups you
were Ron Jeremy if you started when
you're no no no no no no no no no
it sounds like a girl brother I'm not a
hoe because you know why because by the
time I got to high school when guys was
just starting you know getting you know
you're already over it there's no
mystery there yeah I was like man I'm
trying to find a wife yeah I was good
you talk about being a grown man telling
women you have a small dick just to well
I do have to tell that are you I was you
know I'm joking I wouldn't I wouldn't
just Asians it's just an Asian yeah
black girls you'll be like I think long
and strong girl
there's some
rampagers remind me of a teammate that'd
be like oh they want to be grown I'll
teach them grown oh yeah yeah it sounds
like a race
all right uh Hey Oliver take it easy
thank you
talk all this dick game every serious
about it yeah
I'll tell you what I am serious about
Kratom from
what is my life become happy hippo.com
man that's great I want to play it I use
the shots I don't have it here because I
already used it I used to postcard shots
to get the a sour apple they have
gummies
happy info.com you get 20 off when you
stick 23 that's t h i c c 23 on
happyhippo.com best grade of my planner
let's get back
let's have a hippo though
it helped you focus like fires up your
brain oh okay it's like people got like
a limitless Bill your boy Bradley Cooper
Limitless why they call it happy hippo
though that's just the name of the
company happy hip hop it's a cute little
Pink Hippo man okay it's a it's a Kratom
coming in trust it's the Wild Ones it
sounds good though it's great yeah I
asked I I used it forever and I asked
them to be part of the show because I
love it
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I did uh probably four months
ago 3 15 12 times 12 yeah 3 15 12 times
yeah DRT did it yeah
I did 225 40.
yeah probably a few times but that's it
not 12. no maybe two you think he's
lying no no obviously I I posted too
yeah I was gonna say I've seen this
video I'll post it too yeah I deadlift
600. yeah most blew my [__] out I'll
never do that again yeah no more heavy
heavy deadlifts can you betray 15. [__]
no you could if you want if you like
tried it like if you focus on it like
with your build you could easily I
guarantee it am I trying to hit too hard
not to have that power but I never I
never really lift weights I never I'm
not strong that's what I'm saying if you
focus on like even 225 is about doing
repetitions like you just got to build
up to the endurance and take steroids uh
what's up are you hitting them in the
back of the head he did oh that kick
yeah I can't wait for this fight man
well it's been a while
he's getting Mufflers in the back of the
head though
I think the Late Night show might work
yeah with the three of us
on the gay network
with him yeah on Logo TV let's not act
like you didn't admit you chucked Nick
you're coming back
we're going to be standing outside
oh here we go Main Event boys
you feel any type of way you see Jon
Jones fight Rampage or no those days are
over no no I I just had bad blood
we didn't really have that we didn't
really have no bad blood I just I just
really don't like that he kicked my knee
backwards oh yeah I think that kick
should be illegal yeah yeah he's the one
that started the whole Trend yeah yeah
so Rampage referring to kick John and
used like this like it's like a low kick
it's a heel to the knee so Bleak so it
boom so your knee goes like this but
snapping dude's ligament so it changes
your [__] career yeah because he
wants to stop you from going forward
yeah now you will be surprised guys from
being the aggressor yeah it sucks you
know he apologized because um I bumped
into Jones one day and I think La was
there somewhere and he was in the club
and stuff like that and we went and we
went to the table sit down and we had to
clam up on something and you know my
knee is really bad I couldn't do it he
had to hit me up and I'm like he's like
man you [__] up said yeah thanks to
you [__] he was like yeah that's
what I said yeah man he's like oh man
I'm sorry I I felt like it was yes
it's tough to tell with him right like
you'll be sincere but I think he was
sincere on that like yeah his interview
was like man I just want to thank I just
like I dropped that [__] bro just be the
heel yeah be the Joker the UFC lean in
there's a huge fan base yeah yeah oh and
guys
yeah like hamza's done that they started
booming he's like [__] Y'all nobody can
beat me anywhere yeah but bring it on
whoever you want there was uh I forget
who the DN is of the uh I think it's
Thibodeaux rookie he was a rookie for
the Giants literally celebrate next to
the quarterback after they sacked it but
the quarterback was hurt laying on the
ground just squirming he started doing
the snow angel and then when he got on
the sideline he started doing the sleep
like after he knew the dude oh damn but
then played it like he didn't know but
it's like bro lean into it he gives a
[__] if you don't like it stop me yeah
yeah I couldn't if I was him
do a full Lawrence Taylor yeah now you
will see bodied up for days but he does
have a Godsmack tattoo in the middle of
his chest what's that what's God's man
Jim bring up Godsmack the band you don't
know godsmacked the Band
Stand Alone
that's all you got oh yeah yeah it used
to be huge I heard it on road rash the
video game yes Jim bring up the Godsmack
tattoo or Godsmack don't make you feel
good that you said a few words and he he
knew it yeah thank God yeah if you guys
like Stand Alone
look it's the exact same tattoo the far
left
see I don't know much about bands but if
I hear that song I you know yeah they
had some slappers back in the day what
was your song coming out
when I was fighting I had different
songs a lot of times but I have yeah
back in the day when I when I when I was
fighting the pride I had my own song but
then UFC wasn't allow that so I came out
to like um
a couple times yeah is that Rick Ross I
don't know who the [__] that was
that Roy Jones song was so cute I guess
what I've been I've been doing I did
some music in Japan years ago and I'm
finally releasing it oh really yeah I'm
releasing on all the streaming platform
I think March 17th I got a song coming
out called Amy
are the Asian groups it's about Asian
[__]
March 17th yeah it's gonna be on Spotify
yeah yeah when I get back from Thailand
I have a weird bad feeling about this no
I want to be involved it's a it's a EDM
like type of song It'll be dope but I
did this song A long time ago in Japan
you think you're still gonna bang or
because it's so long ago is that like
Affliction it was before it's time
why do I keep coming over and [__]
with you you know I'm just saying hey
you love me if you made it I made it
years ago it sounds like you know I get
knocked down
and then you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah dude
you gotta you gotta have it on your
phone
right now we better watch the main event
we got time play that anger right now
bro which one you give
me song which one amen
let's do both yeah I really want to do
it's a real treat man it's a real
[__] treat to hear this Banger God I
hope
oh
he said I got music coming on March 17th
from a long time ago yeah I just found I
found the release there I didn't want to
do nothing but then I said yo might as
well
get that [__] out into the world you
know if they need it strike while they
are inside brother no I just said [__]
it I'm going to hit release there I got
nothing to lose no when I was fighting
the pride they was trying to turn me
into and I gotta I gotta say hey sexy
you know sexy Yama sings he sells like
Arena's out
uh Pratt was trying to turn me into like
uh they wanted me to rap and stuff in
Japan oh I would love that and so I was
making an album but then I stopped
[__] with pride so I never did that
yeah but you see how you're releasing it
yeah I got the song and I got a joke
dude played no sweaty dick too
yo play which one are you gonna play
right now
alien right now play Aliens hold
it's like an ADM
in I'll snap my dick to this
is that you yeah
way better than I thought yeah all right
I wish I had like a speaker though so
y'all can hear thump though it thumps
oh this is the clean version but
you saying third strap yeah you're
saying third strap this is a clean this
is a clean version I made a second touch
the clean version
how many more words you add to that it's
like I'm saying [__] to That explicit
version there's trap [__]
I just let y'all hear the first void the
first first verse you have a verse in
there
doesn't sound like it
even though you hate me damn no I'm not
mad bro Hey listen hey but listen to
this joke when I did I did a joke one it
was going to be like a uh you know like
a um got some Skrillex [__] that was
dope yeah I thought it was gonna be
terrible the Japanese guy he's a genius
but this but this is the funniest one
I let my boy product or something from
Wu-Tang here it is yesterday he cried he
started crying
I was crying
damn John shorts are too short to be
that thick yeah I'm crying from this
evening
you should probably stop the music just
in case okay
it should have flagged though if he owns
it right
yeah no yeah you can't find this [__] on
the streets either
you don't hear this one you're not
getting released I don't know I don't
think I'm gonna release this one I'm
talking about sweaty dick suck my
sweater yeah I love it yeah I'll start
with this one
but me and will again don't listen to it
yeah
swear
the first song was a banger that was a
real Skrillex that's when you know
you're in the club every night yeah yeah
yeah
the guy I told the guy was before his
time I'm gonna tell you yeah if that was
10 years ago nine years ago [__] he told
me not to say how long ago I made it but
like no [__] it be real bad oh they're
cutting the they can't he can't have
tape on his foot
they said that big toe got to go
he broke right yeah so if that's known
why would he try to do it just to cover
it up it's probably compromised he
doesn't give a [__] look at that pot
Bell he looked like me
yeah it's interesting even when he's
taped like that he knows it's gonna get
cut off no no he probably didn't pass it
he probably did that flip hit a little
different right now here we go now
telling he's a little slower boys
look at that reach so he's the long
streets tied for the longest ever the
only guy that equals his reach is a
seven foot guy named Stefan Stroup he
was some foot tall had the same reach 84
and a half
tied for the longest ride I see this on
paper brother I hate that I hate it yeah
I didn't get the bed out there but I
would have I was gone yeah
but you would have chefchenko in that
parliam [__] it so it don't matter
Fair yeah save money
his footwork the way he is with that
front leg oh he's a yeah he's a better
athlete than Jones
I'm literally making that up too I heard
Rogan no he's a freak athlete Rogan's
right like there's a video of him
dunking a basketball that's nuts
oh windmills what's up I own the music
who's the last guy fought because I saw
him fight the uh Samoan or something
yeah which was electric because that uh
what's his name Francis
chugs out of the shoe yeah yeah the
entertaining bro tied to a boss he's
right number five still in the world
he's a beast
that was a boring fight too yeah for the
mo yeah here's the thing about gone he
won't Force anything he's cool going to
the decision getting booed making it
boring he doesn't take a lot of risk
that's why John's gonna have to force a
little bit here and get him against the
cage it's an interesting fight what do
you think now now you see him come out
you saw the little slow cars I'm gonna
see John this thick so I I guess he
wants the Bell Rings right now it's
tough with those short shorts pulled up
like that
you saw that cartwheel yeah it was a
little difficult yeah you got the big
boy wheel in there what do you think a
rampage I'm thinking why would John come
out of some booty shorts yeah I think
Johnson that's what he does right yeah
when he's 205.
it's a different game
yeah heavyweight boys don't be wearing
them shorts I still think John mops the
floor with him though to be honest
like even though I was going to bed gone
I really do hope John you just want to
see guys it's better for the sport of
job yeah it just is you want John to win
because he got on Daisy Dukes yep there
he goes gotcha gotcha
Rampage Rampage actually you think I'm
gay huh yeah you really do no he goes
that's okay I don't care you should see
his wife though he's he's uh he's
already realized he thinks it's a
cover-up yeah they don't it don't mean
it don't mean no it's a beard no because
you know yeah no because you can be
bisexual people can be bisexual right
he's fluent but for a guy if you
bisexual they're still considered gay
right yeah I don't know how it works
yeah for a woman if they bisexuals
bisexual but before I do if he bisexual
oh he gay really yeah
for the rest of your life for the rest
of your life I thought you had to like
it
[Laughter]
26-1 in that one no contest uh he beat
the [__] out of the guy and got uh no
contest because illegal elbows because
he's whipping his ass so bad a guy named
Matt Hamill
and I hate to take his shine there but I
was the main event on that card
Roy Nelson ultimate that's appropriate
though you said you're a little stat it
was still quiet you had to still add
into the and I did lose because I'm
literally sitting here running for the
ultimate fire finale I lost a Roy I had
four fights he had [__] 30. you know
it's about decision no knockout first
round what he took me down I got up I
was whooping his ass then he hit me with
that right hand oh [__] it's hard
because I'm sitting here watching the
fight and I'm literally you know I'm
feeling it a little bit yeah dog yeah
he's done one dude great career when's
your drinks parents get home Drake
parents your drink when do it when do it
oh he's saying you're babysitting yeah
babysitter
you need to treat that that whiskey like
your parents Jade you not
watched last time so I've been watching
and before you got here Brandon was like
just once once he gets ringing he's like
he's a lot of fun but if he's not drunk
he's not you know he's all right I never
said he's all right yeah you gotta watch
this you got to watch this guy yeah he's
like keep drinking what hotel yeah
oh here we go oh he kicked him in the
nuts what
what what's that seven seconds nine
seconds in gets hit right in the wiener
not the way you want to kick off after a
three-year layoff
those kicks could be oh that's straight
up oh that's right on the the that was
that was strategy that was strategy
years
it slows the guy down
I'm this is so interesting how John's
gonna look here oh if Robert Jones I
kick him right back in the nuts me too
you got to get a kick right back
[__] how long John's gonna
entertain on the feet because obviously
he just oh
and every time God kicks if he answers
it could be a problem for God he's just
trying to get him to the cage and take
him down John is slow look at him look
how you moving he's still technician
though
you're coming up from 205 his belly
shouldn't look like that just saying
and I can't talk but I'm just saying
meanwhile God's built like a Greek
goddess am I right yeah he's in shape no
yeah he is built John just has to use
that footwork not to get [__] that's
uh that's a physique Callum would like
to oh dude I like to get his arms around
that all day yeah
oh there's there's that character
okay look at you slowly missing [__]
but also three-year laps there's me a
little rust everybody gets going all he
needs is one take down oh oh you're
[__] oh [__] you're fine oh [__] oh
this is over there soon I thought he's
going to submit any crazy gun in the
entire Camp don't get taken down say
less one minute into it you think so you
think it's over uh it could be we'll see
if he can hand fight give it to his feet
I don't like to position John's in that
low oh he's trying to get wrist control
though he should just get his back
though he should forget that and get
it's not good for God get his back
yeah John got a good uh red naked oh
[__] oh yeah
that's gonna be a win for gun don't grab
the cage oh
oh oh
he's in trouble oh he's going oh
submission in under two minutes this is
gonna hurt too you think so this right
here on his neck right now it depends
what he does here because it doesn't
look like he's under the chin
but it's definitely gonna strain him if
you're gone what are you trying to do
right now get out get my give get my
neck safe get back to your feet yeah and
hand fights how do you get your neck
safe and get back to you oh my god it's
over yeah that's it yeah oh my God boy
he mopped the floor with that boy he
didn't get touched did not bet that
wasn't me everybody watching long lay
off he's too athletic he went say less
check this out
he [__] there's your World Champ
Heavyweight World Champ
who wants to argue he's not to go that's
for the heavyweight title they can title
he wants to argues not to go go ahead
I'm listening [__] I don't know why
you were looking at me he made it look
easy too this was a good matchup for him
the guy has no grappling got no no
grappling and you saw it he went
straight to him like like butter went
straight to Mound what what just [__]
happened
uh uh the gold the greatest of all time
literally found a guy who's never
followed Grappler got taken down within
the first minute and panicked and got
choked out with a guillotine
god dude what a waste of [__] money
three years off world heavyweight
champion hey acting like I paid for it
what a waste of money but it was some
other good fights on the card hell yeah
that Grandma fight was ridiculous don't
dance in the booty shorts don't oh come
on girls hey bro you look at Village
People tonight in Vegas that boy getting
loose and you sent him that track bro I
see you Arthur go off kid you're right
so Arthur I play I play with Arthur in
uh Washington he's like his last year
was he stun he was solid yeah he was a
solid he was good with the Colts right
he was was he he went to the pro ball
yeah yeah no Chandler Jones I don't know
if he went to the Pro Bowl but he was a
good player I'm almost possibly went to
the pro ball maybe can you look up bring
that up Arthur Jones NFL Arthur Jones
Chandler Jones Arthur Jones all Chandler
Jones and uh Arthur Jones NFL
Jon Jones obviously Arthur Jones pro
ball I play with uh Arthur his brother
who they just showed he's kind of
thicker he's more of a d lineman there's
Arthur right there he didn't even look
Arthur's a good dude though he's [__]
good people click on his uh profile too
we're trying to see if he went to the
pro ball he's a big dude huh yeah hell
yeah it's big dude look at John I mean
his other two brothers outside of being
a light heavyweight they're a d ending
click on his Wikipedia Chandler Jones is
a sack artist he's a [__] yeah he's a
beast he's going down he was with the
Raiders this past year but he was with
the Cardinals I'm talking multiple Time
pro bowler he's with the Patriots what
about Arthur was he a pro
will there go up go up you should see it
up there at the top in that
right there on the right side career
highlights go down on that right go down
Dana looks weathered Super Bowl career
history
no he wasn't no you're thinking of
Chandler go to Chandler he was a Super
Bowl champion yeah Chandler definitely
Pro Bowl definitely yeah Chandler Jones
is a freak monster freak
damn gone didn't land one [__] punch
dude don't kicked him in the nuts
how fast that happens insane
and now Stipe is next
yeah just depends what version of steepe
we get but I don't know who's gonna be
John dude that was insane how fast I was
I I think it kind of sucks how that
ended and yeah they're back together now
I feel Jon Jones fan you know you're
right I I yeah I thought he I thought
but I'm thinking like I'm saying I'm
sitting here with two UFC guys as the
the Casual fan I'm thinking you want to
fight that's how it ended that's what
happened that's his brother right there
he picked it up no that's his dad man
have that hairline
she's back with Malcolm X Man
Don was like God damn and Don't Clap
oh let us know what he says in the
post-fight speech here
that's the easiest fight at John's
career
yeah maybe easier to fight that's insane
man that's insane he didn't get touched
took him down Guillotine Against the
Cage that's maybe easier fight he's ever
had maybe Ryan Bader back in the day
even Shogun give him more of a fight
when he won his first belt
[__] you know he's so happy good for
him though
they're gonna call him Eddie King by
Monday though
yeah I must feel a good three year
layoff all that trauma he's been through
all that [__] when I say trauma is the
trauma he imposed that is true he really
did yeah self-imposed you think he you
think he's done with all that [__] no no
I mean it's just you know I I see I love
Jon Jones I think he's the greatest
fighter of all time I like him when he's
a little wild when I find out he's in
Vegas and Bentley's with strippers I'm
like he about to beat somebody's ass
Georgia yeah he just got caught yeah
he's still thanking God
still thanking everyone for their
prayers
he put that shirt on real quick
I would too I get it yeah
I'm gonna do this
a lot of idiots
good for three years off though
you come in and win the uh heavyweight
that's a heavyweight title yeah yeah
[__] yeah it gets up very athletic
you're the baddest man on the planet if
you was the best man before any of this
the positions proves it three years off
that's Arthur right there my man's put
on some weight all right he retired you
talking about Big Art yeah yeah yeah he
yeah he retired back in you should come
back man absolutely not right Jon Jones
[__] absolutely now I wanna I wanna box
though before I before I get too old I
do want a box who's gonna box what do
you mean by you want a box before you
get too old I want to have a boxing
match
against
a boxer he was trying to fight uh I feel
you but if you could pick who I don't
know I don't know maybe because I feel
like somebody in your position you'd
almost go for like the same
just for my ignorance sake like uh uh
somebody old yeah but you know Mike
Tyson you know how like you know how
like Tyson and my and and uh Tyson makes
sense you know how Tyson and Roy Jones
did the things Roy
joins us compete against Anthony Pettis
yeah that's gonna be good who would you
want to box uh and somebody because
clearly it'd be your name yeah somebody
somebody that that's not as good at
boxing because I want to have my first
box of man I want to you know have some
be competitive how big is uh Jake Paul
not that big no no I'm 100 I had to lose
100 pounds to fight Jake Paul yeah
see you whoop Jack I beat the [__] out
of Jake but I have to lose 100 pounds to
fight him what about like Evander
Holyfield to Roy Jones like a legend
fight all right I want a box of Van
delay silver oh see that'd be dope
because you guys are one and one we four
we're two and two two and two
well I like the box of boxes would you
do bare knuckle no [__] them yeah that's
insane yeah that's stupid
they break their fists all the time they
get cut up some of it's nuts man I
really don't get paid that much dude
some like Paige VanZant gets paid like
the big dogs get paid like Mike Perry
you know Mike Perry's fighting uh that's
right Luke rockhold I want to see that
one let's get fight yeah they just
announced it crazy
he was a stud back in the day yeah it's
one of the best 85ers on the planet for
a number of years Super stuck yeah
it's a tough fight for steepe
depends what version stupid we get where
does Jon Jones what's he doing number
one like what's the plan just now he's
gonna fight Steve he can't touch so he
can fight next week so he'll probably
fight what are we in we're in March
April May I've been fighting the summer
card fight that big summer card in July
fights eBay then he'll probably fight a
third time
he'll probably fight uh the Curtis
blades after that because he beats that
Russia there was a there was a time
where he wasn't fighting just because he
wasn't getting enough money yeah or he
was trying to commit he just wasn't any
contenders but not heavyweight there's
some contenders like Curtis blades to
give him some Fritz
um because he's a wrestler
um and then you know Steve is there I
still think Francis and him are gonna
fight I think if Francis fights like a
Deontay Wilder and does well the UFC
would have him back because Francis is
still the honest in the world always
beat him
and when you say when you talk about
Francis fighting um Deontay Wilder
Deontay Wilder you talk about him well
he lost because he's wanting to leverage
he's going to pursue that to get a
bigger cash no doubt he's gonna make
more cash fighting Deontay Wilder or
Anthony Joshua or Tyson Fury they would
fight is that what he's doing that's
right currently yeah he left the UFC to
pursue that I think he does that and
comes back to UFC and fights his job
because Dana can say I'd never sign him
he's going to sign him especially in
some weird world if he knocked out
Deontay Wilder which isn't too
far-fetched if he did he'll be a huge
dog if he got it done you're telling me
Francis got him coming off The Knockout
of Deontay Wilder versus Jon Jones isn't
[__] the biggest US
how does something like that not get
done Dana White your boy talk to him he
said my boy no I haven't met him he had
him on the show and he's like oh like
he's on your podcast yeah but he's like
that's laugh fight leagues
[Laughter]
we're going to powerslide next week he
invited us out so we're you know we're
trying where's it in Vegas right yeah it
sounds Apex Center oh damn you're gonna
be out there no [__] no I'm being Talent
that's right yeah
keep us posted be out there for a month
yeah I'll be out there for a month
now when you say Dana so what keeps that
from happening because they asked well
because there's a negotiation they tried
paying Francis the most of any
heavyweight fighter ever he said and
France was like no I'm worth more than
that so when you say ever he said he
goes does that look like contractually
we don't know because you think uh uh I
don't know the guarantee because he said
he'd make that means more than Brock
Lesnar who's highest paid ever but
man probably you know 15 10 15 million
but he's like no I'm gonna go fight
deontarella I can make more money and
then come back and dance like we're
never gonna have him back which he says
that stuff all the time
yeah yeah negotiation so trust me if
Francis does well against Dante Wilder
of Tyson Fury he's fighting Jon Jones by
next year got you and that's the [__]
fight because I don't think anybody's
gonna beat John no not is there a world
where Jon Jones goes back down like
heavy giving away he looks no never why
not why would he easier fights now
um who's in light heavy uh light heavy
you have Yuri there you have uh Jan
blockovich because he doesn't want to
cut weight because now he's he did all
he could at light heavyweight there's no
huge stars there all his big fights are
at heavyweight so why not uh double it
up why not be like a champion is that
not it's not possible he's too heavy to
count to 205 now he was like two you
think so the way he looks now he wanted
to do it to do too much at his age would
be too much okay heavyweights for him
and look he didn't get touched bro
the most athletic one we have but if if
you're saying there's nobody in the
light heavy world then why not go down
and just be a champ champ and I'm I'm
truly amazing you're any casual it's
awful cutting weight at his age to Awful
205 was it how old how old is he 35 35
that [__] does yeah cutting to 205 and
you weigh 250. he waited at 250 250.
it's a miserable cut now you can eat
whatever he wants he looks good his
cardio's good he didn't get in touch he
said cardio is good he didn't really
physically he didn't really get tested
in the cardio realm no no no so we don't
know yeah but we'll see it's easiest
fight of his entire life that's got to
make you feel that win right there has
got to make you like all the [__] he's
been like just absolute Cloud Nine like
man that [__] lasted barely over a
minute one of the highest highs ever had
yeah two minutes yes but the fight you
know look at that
uh it's dope that's a good shot
the kid's hair is awful
why are they in suits
good for him man yeah good for him
report his role now
I remember that reporter right there
yeah
he's a good guy really good guy the dude
that he just died yeah yeah that's
that's reporters row there yeah
yeah he must be fit Oh there's uh Alex
Murdoch's son with red hair there who's
Alex Murdock he's the murdering dad shot
his son and wife just got sent into two
life sentences
he looks identical to him the older son
who's still on the loose
that story is trash do you see that Alex
Murdock doc on Netflix
I've been seeing it you gotta get
involved because I started on we we were
thinking about watching but we ended up
watching uh uh what is it uh shrink oh
yeah on Apple Plus shrinkers
shrinking with Will Ferrell no not Will
Ferrell the old boy from uh Jason
um oh Bateman Jason Segal oh yeah yeah
from uh Forgetting Sarah Marshall any
good dude awesome awesome we gotta check
out that Alex Murdock doctor Hey Brother
[__] Bro watch the uh I just got time
your honor on Showtime
stresses me out what it was uh your
honor about he's a judge and his son
kills a kid but he kills uh the head
Mafia guys kid so he's like trying to
cover it up it's [__] good judge's
kid kills the head and Mafia guys kid
and the judge is trying to cover it up
cover his trash
I don't think so Alex Murdoch true story
yeah yeah they're talking about like the
all the rich families in the South and
he was a prosecutor it's dope is that it
chin yeah can we talk about jelly though
is it over do we say dude I had a great
time did we not talk about a great time
no I talked about Joe yeah he couldn't
make it uh for me touring dates I am in
Oklahoma City next week Thursday Friday
Saturday breakdown Comedy Club then I
end March into coma Washington Tacoma
comedy club is March 23rd through the
25th uh then Atlanta 13th through the
15th and then I'm going to Europe I'm in
Belfast June 15th and then after Belfast
of scrinch if chin Scrolls down Glasgow
June 17th Manchester June 18th London
June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd Dublin June
25th about to be lit but Oklahoma City
you are up this coming week Thursday
Friday Saturday breakdown economy Club
tickets at thickboy.com Rampage Love You
Will Compton love you guys thanks for
doing it Jon Jones is the goat told you
we're out